two
my friends
[Music]
welcome it's monday august 29th
a sad summer day
as you guys can see from the title
what was the title where our channel
might our channel may be arrayed our
channel may be deleted yes
before i bring that
shocking terrible revelation i am
obligated to read this ad
so you have to wait 15 seconds
this back-to-school season this is back
to school season let hello fresh handle
dinner
their quick and easy meals take the
stress out of meal time
even on hectic weeknights
get 16 free meals across seven boxes
with code h3tv 16
at hellofresh.com
h3tv16 we love hellofreshman this is
oh
wait go back up
down down down stop stop right there
down stop oh dang
okay
wow
that could be yours and more at
hellofresh.com
h3tv16 thank you thank you
yes
welcome everybody first of all zack is
back welcome back zac thank you thank
you very much thank you very much
appreciate it appreciate it
although you may not have a job for long
clearly not
[Laughter]
if you did good he did good yeah he well
you you were you watching when i was in
and out i saw the flock of [ __ ] um yeah
the flakka thing kind of took on a life
it's of its own they did yeah did you
think the flakka was funny or um yeah i
did i thought i thought it was funny i
thought it was good do you have any
notes for a b not that it matters
i'm just kind of curious you know in
general like a comprehensive analysis um
when when part of my job is i like to
view it as like
music is like a bed it's like the frame
yeah of the show
so that and i i mean you know that's
just constructive criticism it's it's
just there were times
[ __ ] was very random
yeah yeah it didn't make a lot of sense
yes
but other than that aby did a really
good job and i'm proud of him
thank you
gotta say
pretty good pretty nice comments from
zach you know
are you are we gonna continue the flock
of legacy zack we'll see what happens if
the time's right you know it's all about
timing it's up to you now it's in it's
in here the flop is in your hands now
yeah right right did you did you take
some flakka with you to your desk
maybe to my desk no
okay so the is in zach's hands
there's one
yeah
so who played that that was me okay okay
there's one other thing i wanted to ask
before i get to this horrible horrible
update i just i never asked you guys but
there's a stool
in the bathroom under the toilet
oh i came back from michigan i've been
wondering about that yeah is it the
squatty potty yeah is that you
no it's not mine but i noticed who put a
stool there sam i see you grinning
squatty potty gang
so you put a so that stool is you're
doing yes and so what you put your feet
up and it makes things go easier yes
you're in the optimal position
yeah because i never i just i didn't
even know why there's either life will
be different i thought it was a segment
i missed
it's kind of in the way because
sometimes i pee i'm going to pee and
there's like the whole stool there right
do you guys do the men agree
not only that i i have to admit i you
pee on it no i know
no i noticed that it was there and i
i gave it i gave it a shot
and i i did not go
well
i didn't even know that's what it was
before yeah no i knew it was poor but
okay so what'd you think i
i'm not a fan
you didn't it didn't improve your
experience even it didn't you didn't
like it maybe maybe my legs are too long
but i found it to put me in an extremely
like precarious
position so it made things like i was
like maybe it's not the right height for
you i guess or something i i i'm willing
to give it another chance if if i find
one that's
calibrated to my body but i mean that
sam's feet were like super high
uh like how high are your feet up sam
when you're using that it's comfortable
to me okay okay are your legs at like an
at like a
well parallel with the with the you know
ground like in a squat
not like uh are your knees elevated
though are you like your legs you know
perfect oh no no like they're elevated a
little bit i found it yes i was like i i
can't even get into the position here
like i was like rolled like halfway back
like you don't know what your
performance is like i guess not no
cirque du soleil and well ian then if
she if this is a sam thing i'm sure you
you've been introduced to this probably
you have i'm imagining you have one at
home right of course yeah yeah yeah yeah
i've used it are you squat gang
i use it um flap those cheeks i don't
know if the performance is like
that much more aerodynamic on the
release um i don't dislike it it's fine
you kind of have like a good l shape
so i don't know what does it do for you
that's so wonderful sam
he had to bring it to work it just puts
you in like perfect position i don't
know i feel like it's it's helped me i'm
an ibs queen okay okay so i think that
it helped me personally i don't know
okay all right sam that's ours from home
right or did you order no i i have two
there's one here and there's one at home
she had like a particular bad like meal
day
and was like
i saw her running to the car with the
squatty pot she's like i'm gonna need
this at the office today oh wow good
okay you just never know you know yeah i
mean the only time i see a stool is you
know so that theodore can reach the
toilet so i don't even know what to do
with that
i'll try it i'll try it next time give
it a sh i'm telling you we have one i
got my parents one for christmas we have
one at home
chantal likes i'm not a fan of it so it
seems like the women love it yeah so far
it's for the girls women love it maybe
we should make an issue podcast branded
uh poop stool
i would endorse that so hard
petty fresh poop stool yes
one of the most successful uh shark tank
products is the school that was a shark
tank product yeah and it's like one of
the most popular
oh i'm out of it what it's just a stool
how can how do they cla how can you even
like copyright that well it's configured
directly to you know fit nicely around
the base of the toilet
if it was so it's a
simple idea why don't you think of it
ethan
you think of it
maybe i'll make my own what are they
gonna sue me that's what i said if i
make a teddy fresh squatty potty what
are they going to do about it
multiple brands make i think like tushy
makes one there's like a bunch of
different
brands sushi maybe even dude wipes maybe
they have something similar too what do
we do about it yeah because i i won't
use it unless it's branded for men it's
embarrassing otherwise
yeah
um oh yeah so here's the lore bobby and
judy appeared on shark tank
seeking an investment of 350 000 for 5 i
mean these people are out of their mind
350 for five percent for a stool
stool you know what's funny about that
you're making a stool while using the
stool
yeah you see
that's like a jordan peterson revelation
what is the stool
the stool is what makes the stool now
there's a definition
thank you
uh lori finally agreed to 350 000 for 10
percent what the [ __ ]
i guess she made a good deal i would
have told that person idiot to get lost
but i'd have been wrong you've been
wrong squatty potty ladies and gentlemen
did your parents like it when you when
you bought it for them yeah it changed
them they were like oh my god i can't
believe we didn't know about this
i'm telling you wow it's the best you
have these glasses changed my life
wow welcome back jack
thank you
i don't i think ab the problem you had
with the sound bites was just the
systems he has over there is
overwhelming if you're not familiar with
it that's part of it um yeah and he has
them labeled really interesting a lot of
them
some
it's maybe intentional i don't know but
yeah some of them are hard to find some
of them i was goofy you think he makes
it
uh
it's just how my brain processes it's
definitely joker brain yeah
well he's fast man
yeah he's the goat he's the best
you're get you're good though you did a
really good job hold on hold on after
the show judy and bobby sold the squatty
potty for 12.3 million what is going on
it's a plastic stool wow
configuration it's like it's a stool a
small stool a stool to make stool it's
not just a small stool i don't know why
you keep saying that i can't believe you
bring it out someone break someone go
grab it and let's look at it
i mean i'm serious this is not a 12
million dollar idea
the name alone is just alone
it's just a stool i trust them
i think you can
oh [ __ ]
oh thank you noodle soup says we're 134
million views away from a billion that's
actually insane
billion views [ __ ]
here's a 12 mi 12.3 million dollar
i think the plastic
see that's not just a stool look at the
shape
it's specifically formulated
is this even the brand though it says
simple by squatty
oh it is a squatty potty this is the
brand
okay that's the one test it out
take a [ __ ] right now
live on this show
i think that your seat right now is a
little higher than a toilet here let me
go let me go down a bit
so probably probably around there
maybe even a little more i'm not quite
sure
maybe my camera wasn't the best option
i'm [ __ ] my pants what do you do
with your hands put them like this
that's kind of formal i don't know i
feel like i tend to lean forward or i'll
have my phone or something
have your phone lean back this is this
is as low as it goes
okay well we'll give it give it a shot
later okay i'm just i'm trying to
picture myself
do they have a wide one so i can open up
you ever hit you over straddle it like
this kind of on the edge i don't
personally but i think you could
it's just about the elevation it doesn't
matter if you straddle clap those cheeks
fantastic okay congratulations squatty
potty people
huge exit for lori
i gotta go wash my hands because i'm
sure there's pits on that thing
right there you know what i mean right
yeah no it's definitely covered in fecal
matter
and other various things
you guys want to see something cool
uh oh yeah show that
my tooth fell out before the show my
my fake tooth that i had put in last
week anyone got a dollar yeah i was
eating it i was eating chex mix yeah
that's why i put it in here so i give it
tooth fairy
was it the ride chip that took it out
i'm not sure i'm not sure i was trying
to chew on the other side of my mouth i
just fell out it was the right trip well
we know a really good dentist um his
name's krentis
not what i was going no his name is uh
jimmy dr james weiner from winer um
dentistry
weiner winer we're having fanfare okay
i'd laugh at all his jokes if he hooks
it up yeah exactly you gotta fly to
jersey though yeah you gotta play with
jersey or maybe he can do it when he
does wall-e's
hmm
yeah so i just want to point out i'm in
excruciating pain but
i love my job
and i'm here and you couldn't get an
appointment yeah until tomorrow that too
not to sell you out thank you kim thank
you dan
thank you dan uh dan the audio is
clicking occasionally with peace and
love yep um
sure is is that my mic
no okay
if i could get a usb card in our console
uh having
slight digital audio snaps every once in
a while and it's something
that i have been trying to troubleshoot
for about two months and it won't stop
we don't know what it is
well i know what it is but i don't know
how to get it to stop so any uh
audio engineers out there with extensive
experience with the behringer x32
console with the usb
card and it's audio interface software
for windows uh
please uh reach out to me with any
suggestions you may have
i walk away for one minute you guys are
doing tech [ __ ] expects
you're losing um
yeah okay all right that was fun
thank you uh prolapsed penguin for the
20 thank you for the gifted thank you
all right it's time that we address the
title i don't want to put this off
anymore
um
[Music]
as you guys can read clearly our channel
may be deleted
as you guys know we have one strike
on our channel
if we get two more channels gone
if we get one more
we're
gone for two weeks
and i think we lose a lot of other stuff
but it's sketchy
strikes
it's dicey some say the dices
yeah so i just want to say
that today i want to announce
that
our strike is gone [ __ ]
suck it haters keep trying l l l this is
what it this is what happens when you
[ __ ] take the l's again and again and
again and again keep trying keep trying
[ __ ] because i got zero strikes zero
yeah
haters this one goes out to you flocka
zero
strikes
good standing hey
hey yo you know what they should do to
the nra just kidding
[Music]
just just kidding
just kidding but we've got zero strikes
i can do whatever i want hey
[Music]
okay and i'm not even gonna lie
there was a couple moments during that
strike i thought we might be getting
another one
but somehow we didn't
see okay let's go
[Music]
hey let's go let's go
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Music]
keep starts crying right now yeah
tater tots are crying right now
so much tears it's breaking my heart
[Music]
zero strikes come on put your hands in
the air
[Music]
zero stretch come on put your hands in
the air suck it
suck this tiny jewish dick let's go
put your hands in the air
you're doing it wrong
[Music]
there we go baby it's gone
we're free it's awesome
sunshine why is the
title our channel may be deleted then
well that was true
when now it's not
anything could happen in life anything
could happen dan when are you going to
come to terms with that
we could lose our job security at any
second dude you know this you almost
lost your job dan you should be you
should be happy right now up yours woke
more or less you know what i got for you
literally lying no i'm not lying to his
audience can someone at least [ __ ]
enlighten ethan klein
why don't you record that [ __ ] dude
judas ass dan
the scorpion chair talking [ __ ] i love
that so much dude
wow that feels good man
i was stressed in those three months
that was a long three months yes sir i
was scared we're free
but we're free
and that's why we're going to do our
best to get another strike today but you
know we got we're good i'm just saying
like
now's the time
i can go buck wild oh you take a week
off
yeah it's just it's just a week off it's
fine
it's time to go buck wild
seven days a week
so death threats or any or
threats of terrorism is all on the table
table baby it's all good let's go
let's freaking go
anyway guys yes yes it's a reason to
celebrate
um
but we got a great show here we're gonna
have a lot of fun
zach
we got a little video from your show at
the viper room yes
okay let's check it out
[Music]
you're not playing copyrighted music no
these are all my teams okay
[Music]
he's going to claim you though
oh
the damn of hendricks is back
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he's a funny guy
yeah what you gotta get jimmy lee up
there with you just emcee that [ __ ] i
see jimmy lay on on stage inside of zach
in that moment dude how are you guys how
are we doing
bingo
bingo yeah so the viper room's kind of a
is that that's a big venue right i mean
is that that's not the place right but
it's it's a very uh famous thing very
famous we we packed it it was a good
time uh great opener
everyone that came out thank you so much
it was a lot of fun and um yeah it was
overall a great time
your next show's at the troubadour true
that's the big one right troubadour
about it but dan dan says that's a big
deal the troops troubadour
january 13th it's an all ages show we're
doing so um
that's gonna be a lot of fun bring your
kids
sure bring your kids yeah
let's see baby oh and well also uh we're
also thinking about planning a live show
here pretty soon uh-huh that's gonna be
fun man it'll be a lot of fun
but pretty soon we mean um
probably this winter like near the end
of this year oh is it what is that yeah
i mean we just you got to start planning
for a way in advance
i've i've i'm warming to the ideas what
i mean because before we had one live
show was great everyone had a great time
it was super fun i loved it
and
i don't know why but we just never got
around to planning another one but we're
gonna do one in l.a
this winter
do it live
so moving on
i want to ask you guys a question okay
i was supposed to do a photo shoot for
teddy fresh to promote the peanuts
collab
and i'm afraid i kind of
papa john commented on this
dude papa john is the top
post bro papa bless
yo papa we love you papa
yeah so i was supposed to do a post
promoting
the peanuts drop and i think i just kind
of got lost
in the concept people keep telling me to
work out so i put on my new teddy fresh
muscle tea and got to work it's like i
don't think anyone's going to buy
peanuts
from this
i am but did you guys like this i wasn't
sure i thought this was great it was
great hilarious i'll leave that question
up to you to answer
yeah so i was hitting the um
obviously the weights
the treadmill the peloton
i was doing you can't see but i was
stretching my legs i was doing leg lifts
burned a lot of calories this day
actually you went for a run on the
streets yeah
yeah
yeah
this pic reminded me of like rushmore
when bill murray smokes oh
yeah yeah so it's a good day
burned a lot of calories okay i'm glad
you guys liked it
apparently it's also a promo for teddy
fresh
[Laughter]
here's another one we did on tick tock
this one i was less sure i was about to
erase it and
what why do you work i don't know if
it's just a bad tick tock or or if tick
tock is like holds it for review you
know what i mean
why is it not getting very many likes
yeah it just gets stuck at like
oh 87 000 you know what i mean tick tock
is my workout but here it is i don't i
don't know if this you guys like the
sound i picked why do you work out
what why do you work out
to look cooler during sex
not for health reasons no you gotta
have sex and look cool at the same time
but you should work out because it it's
healthy for your heart that's right
live longer have more cooling and sex
but
looking cool during sex doesn't really
matter
that's the part that i can work out
because
dabbing off the sweat with the pattern
yeah of course bro you gotta do it i'm a
savage you gotta do it
the crocs walking side oh there you go
it's also really really really good yeah
that was great
there's a little theory going around on
reddit about why you wanted to do this
photo shoot i sent it and discord you
did there's a theory yeah
uh-oh
i'll tell you guys if it's right right
now
did ethan uh post this just so he could
eat a bunch of fast food
i'll have you know
the cigarettes i threw out
the fast food all hit the trash actually
i saved the meat and fed it to the dogs
didn't touch this
i was good man i was good i threw it all
out i was you guys would have been proud
of me you off the ciggies completely now
off the cigs really
huh off this eggs when did that happen i
mean ever since i started chewing
nicotine gum oh okay that shit's like
changed me bro all right
like i used to come into the office and
out and then i would see zach and be
like yo it's hard it's like impossible
to resist i'd be like yo let's have a
sig
but i chew a gum right before i get to
the office and i don't even
i don't even think about it i smoke
marijuana so i don't beat my wife and
children
i said cigarettes but i got you
so yeah i've been off cigs for a couple
months
doing pretty good on my diet there's
just so much fat to burn it's hard to
notice any any weight movements
but i've been trying i'm making an
effort on everything you know
i don't want to die oh you know what we
did we took a bunch out and threw it out
so it looked like i ate it
you know what i mean sure yeah
was it me yeah just wasting food
yes starving
children in pakistan kids in africa
would have eaten this chocolate cake do
not waste that sweet milk
to be honest i think the kid hungry kids
would probably die if they ate a big mac
i don't think their bodies could digest
that
that [ __ ]
that's hardly qualifies as food yeah
they're better off eating like [ __ ]
roots or some [ __ ]
bark yeah
bark anyway what do you cam you could
say that talk to me baby all right
you're doing great keep up the great
work dude thanks bro um what what's what
are you talking about though
on your diet and exercise you're doing a
great job and i hope you
wish continued success on it i didn't
want to sound like a simp on air but now
i'm being did you notice that i lost
weight are you just saying you do no you
do look thinner in those photos and i i
did notice yeah i agree
i never trust people when they tell me
that i well i was doing it intentionally
to be encouraging on the side here but i
i did notice
thank you
thank you guys you know what's a great
workout is that metaverse helmet i got
one of those myself over the weekend oh
that's a workout
what were you doing in the metaverse uh
beat saber it's like
it was
that i could definitely see winding yeah
there's also like exercise
games on the on the outside too
wow okay maybe i should get one for him
it's just so cool you don't have to set
up an area yeah no it's it's awesome in
our small apartment we have enough room
for it
also speaking of the metaverse that was
a huge hit you guys seemed to love that
bit which was
very fun so
i guess we got to keep doing metaverse
gags well i got another one on the way
so we'll have two
um
somebody had suggested i guess in a
youtube comment that we use a second
unit as sort of a camera person such a
good oh which is a great idea so i
ordered another one that's coming in a
few days uh our first one technically is
still banned until friday so um it's
good that we have alt so that we can ban
evade
the meta person
but now we have a second one so that uh
we can get a third person shot you can
see my avatar yeah i got mine right here
too
yeah but yours is uh a one i know you
can't join us
well we can play older games together if
you guys wanna you know what's
you know what's [ __ ] up when we first
were looking into the uh horizon you
know zucks game
uh
on their website
it said it was for the oculus and oculus
two
because i think originally it was um but
it still says that on the website and it
goes so far as letting you download the
app and everything on
uh on cam's thing and then you load up
the app so it launches and you get to
the menu and it's like oh you need the
oculus 2 for this
you need the oculus 2 to play that [ __ ]
yeah it's like that's like basic like
why it's [ __ ] it's so that you buy
the name bro that's some what yeah
i feel like it can definitely handle
yeah it's not advanced at all it's so
basic [ __ ]
one of those ti calculators
yeah that's goofy
but yeah they hadn't even updated their
website to to indicate that so on meta's
own website it said you could use the
original oculus two
well we'll plan more it'll be it'll be
fun you know
um
house of the dragon episode two i i feel
like we can't really talk about it
without spoiling
yeah
yeah
it's already starting to lose me a
little bit though
by episode two it seems the consensus is
that people did a lot of people saying
they liked it more than the first
episode did you watch it uh
no i didn't get a chance to watch it yet
tonight i will
i it didn't lose me but it was there was
a moment where i was a little like
here we go really here we go really
anyone else
shame nobody watching me and dan are the
only ones
on this [ __ ] i i i've never watched game
of thrones
never know jack are you i just
my bad
just kidding i want to start game of
thrones wait what i said our our bad
we're not nerds
oh you haven't watched it either no but
i am going to start game of thrones yeah
i'll follow up on my prom not that big
of a deal should watch lord of the rings
first that's friday
that i'm that i'm excited for
jimmy lee posted this check out jimmy
lee's like off the rails bro
i mean he's been [ __ ] posting on
instagram but this one definitely caught
my eye
wait what happened no post yet what
happened jimmy oh there there
like he's just been so off the rails
look at this [ __ ] when you're stoned at
your minimum wage kitchen job and you
see jimmy lee walk in with the camera
crew
[Music]
dude his man is look at this [ __ ] i just
gave me a gackle welcome to jimimal
jimmy maul crossing
with me and ela in it and jimmy what's
up absolutely blown out
lighting i want to speak to mason i'm
more i'm now officially more interested
in jimmy's
social media management and i wonder how
much she's paying him for this here's
the thing though there's people more and
more sending him these memes so it's not
just mason i don't think right now it's
multiple people i say there's a whole
think take yeah um well let's check this
one out my italian ass hates keemstar
his dates could be his daughter's not
very slamming ugly too in my
professional dentist's opinion bad teeth
too
this is the same [ __ ] photo of
himself now i don't condone that message
i think keemstar is
perfectly fine the way he is
he's beautiful everyone's beautiful he's
beautiful like everyone's beautiful
inside and out
i just want to be clear because some
people some people times they say
everybody's beautiful in their own way
he's beautiful in that way
not in any other way sorry
he's beautiful in his own particular way
yeah and like the snowflake every
snowflake's unique kind of way but not
in any other way i just want to make
clear
sorry
sorry why is um
beautiful is that
nice
is that uh
on stage left
what gym on stage left
oh yeah he's not very slamming what are
you doing there because he's italian
oh we just needed allies wait who's
italian i don't think jimmy i don't know
i don't think he's italian yeah wait
nobody here's anything ethan bradberry
likes to pretend he's
even bribery is not even italian no no
come on dude he's like he's an arab yeah
i didn't know that yeah
hey forget about it huh
ethan
you come to me
do you know my children are seven
percent italian
i'm so small in the chair
hold it
you come to me with these memes
kiss my italian ass
i wanna check
whose ass is italian
maybe your girlfriends
i hope mason's italian at least
mason are you italian
it's it's a disgrace
come here and appropriate my culture
the italians
we have a unique culture and identity we
are a race of people
i will not stand this italia phobia
cultural appropriation chameleon
jimmy lee
jimmy lee
jimmy
i don't know
he texts me something um last week that
made my jaw drop really what a a request
from him
tell me
he um
[Laughter]
i guess i'm just gonna have to read it
to you
um
it has to do with his merch
it has to do with what his his merch
he wanted us to take a picture in his
shirts
post it to our personal instagrams like
my main one yeah and then on the podcast
one he wants us to plug him big time we
owe him big time we owe him everything
he didn't even send enough shirts for
all of us
my jaw dropped read it read it okay hold
on
jimmy he he yo he's hustling man you
gotta ask you know the grind don't stop
you gotta ask if you don't ask you never
know he's all zach can i ask
can i ask favor of you i'm like what's
up he said this would greatly help me
could the crew wear t-shirts i sent take
an image put them on your instagram and
also send to me and put on mine it can
help me on sales we have coming jimmy
what do you even need merch sales for
and i'm like grab a roast rice bro so
i'm like you want us to promo the shirts
he's all please and put on our personal
instagram dude
how many of us are there there's like 10
of us total right nathan and ela he sent
us five shirts
and then he wants us to all put him on
hundreds of thousands of pounds
if you're comfortable with that your
call on instagrams you have and h31 if
you're comfortable dude i love that
jimmy if you don't ask you never know no
it's true but my jaw dropped if we maybe
we should do it if he fixes my tooth
i'll i'll wear his shirt the biggest
marketing campaign we've ever done
oh jimmy's let me see give me a merch
store i'm actually curious i'm not i'm
not trying to get anyone to spend money
on this just to be clear i just want to
know
what kind of merch i'd be i'd be
promoting in this hypothetical
marketing blitzkrieg
a
truly jimmy where jimmy where
yo
yo who doesn't want an audio audio audio
shirt
to a beautiful new york backdrop
work with me
jimmy this is
this is so interesting
better call jimmy he's got this whole
better call saul versus jimmy lee
campaign this shirt's fire i have
histrionic personality design
real quick fanfare
yo kev's got it did you buy that or was
that sent to us this is one of the ones
he sent to us you want the other options
over there anyone else want to wear one
that's the best one yeah this is a good
one yeah fanfare did they did he signed
them for us or anything no
i think they're just print on demand
watch the latest episode what is this
this is his whole he's got these new
campaigns where he goes against people
so like jimmy versus it's all good
yeah
okay so
so guys um
don't waste your money on this please
buy teddy fresh yeah buy teddy fresh
if i were to buy one that would
definitely be this one
if i were to buy one it'd be the purple
one i think you want that purple one
yeah
um
let me see
i have historic purse that's like his
new catch phrase i love that you like
this one just classic yeah i think he
sent one of those
i like that one too
i think it's funny
bro what the [ __ ] is the posture
also like it's photoshopped poorly
that's so bad he's made of wow
that is so funny dude
this one's kind of fire what do we think
audio audio audio
zach was joking that he was going to
wear that to his show yeah that's what i
was going to wear the viper room oh i
saw really funny suggestions to put
jimmy lee into the metaverse and do a
set at the comedy club i love that idea
does anyone else love that idea think
about it logistically though how do we
get him in there his kids could do it
his kids are slick they're young
they're young bucks
slick with technology damn what's that
face
i feel like he would still manage to
i mean even if they got him into it
you still have to manipulate the
controls to like walk around they just
put them on stage and he does the rest
you wouldn't know
i think it's funny the only thing is i
don't know how long he'd last in the
meadowverse i feel like he'd get banned
after like one joke that's fine that'd
be great he'd want to be with the live
audience he wouldn't give a [ __ ] about
this is live this is live of the future
let's do a poll because there seems to
be some conflicting uh opinions should
we get jimmy to do a set
in the metaverse
now he's gonna have to buy his own
headset
he won't even send a shirt
he won't even send us [ __ ] shirts
come on this is a big opportunity for
him
[Music]
jimmy's gonna buy his own headset it's
not that bad it's like 400 bucks
now i'm voting yes obviously i'm a fan
of the idea
and i promise i'm not going to get
offended
by his i mean i will be offended but i
can't you know
70 want to see this guys
get your votes in because your votes
matter
this is a democracy here at the hv
podcast
what about the last vote where we said
no more jimmy yeah once a year that one
i don't think yes it did year one they
changed
every this is a recount man okay this is
a
a new referendum
also he's not there physically there's a
barrier right he's independence a little
bit
people seem to want it i mean dude it's
such a funny idea you guys know it is
he'll be do we have him like do
dentistry in vr
[Music]
interesting
i thought jimmy once every six months we
had a deal yeah so so maybe that we'll
just give him an early credit
get out of here text him see if he's
interested zach if he's not already
watching he's gonna ask me a million
questions about what the [ __ ] is a
metaphor that's a segment on its own
just helping him with that i would
actually like to record that yeah and
listen back to it
i'll message him thank you
also uh howie's back on tick tock
destroying people this is what was pages
um
thank god
what is this
i've seen this before i think they're
like
i think they're like
spitting out their stomach or something
i remember re
learning about this fish does anyone
have any intel on this
this is what life was like before kovan
you can't do any of the fun stuff
anymore
remember was that a worm this is what
life dude fowley [ __ ] shame on you
bro that is so messed up that's
disturbing me more than the prolapse
it was like before kovid you can't do
any of the fun stuff anymore
remember
stop it
nothing why are you doing this did howie
really think we forgot is the top
comment what do we do about it
howard i still don't see an apology for
that video yes that video
please address the video nothing
um
okay we found out
it's a monster fish
eel meal
um
that's not the important part of the
link that was just sent
it's not
yeah the important part is that it's
fake the bizarre video features
two dead fish
a video shows two monster fish
exchanging an eel meal
miscaptioned
okay
passing an eel meal from one's mouth to
the other has widely circulated on
social media viewers be warned the
following video is weird possibly
disturbing and just all around gross
okay
an indian based youtuber
posted it
yeah there's been a lot of drama
surrounding these kind of videos because
they like
they like do weird [ __ ] with live
animals that they capture and they fake
fake it being natural
bro i've seen i've seen people like
on tick tock and youtube i don't know
how these channels are allowed to do it
but it's like fake animal rescue where
they obviously put the animal in this
perilous uh position
it's just horrific i just can't stand it
man
you know the videos where they like fish
fish
yes with coke and [ __ ] yes that's all
like fake
a live fish it's awesome it's so [ __ ]
up it's all fake and it's all animal
torture yep
so it's just a hoax
using dead animals
howie do you see what you're doing
this is howie
shame on you howard
nothing
people are saying dawn in the metaverse
now we're
now we're talking that's a way better
idea life was like she'd be so cute in
the metaverse she'd go up to people be
like hey hey what's up what's up
let me tell you about butterflies
maybe we could put her on stage at a
stand-up and just do an info info on
butterflies yeah just that educate
people
is but is this kovid related uh
and if so
what do we do about it what do we do
about it ow
also this is super exciting um
martin
made a video about me and ela this is
we made a date and approved naturally yo
we had a date night and we got bottled
uh sparkling water
and they gave us this water this was the
best part of the meal
called farella sparkling water
naturally carbonated water and i was
like yo martin was going to love this
[ __ ]
and he did you guys
this is martin-approved naturally
carbonated
hello everybody here smart new personal
waters for me ethan
what a nice water uh-huh
i'm so happy that you enjoyed farewell
natural occurring bubbles with the tds
of
1285 from italy great choice
and remember everybody
water is not just i'm not gonna lie i
love that water that water was
interesting it was different dude
naturally carbonated how's that even
possible
thank you martin chug in the water
yeah but also martin's in a bit of
controversy
this is really interesting
someone is trying to expose him on tick
tock is that how does this [ __ ] blow
your mind or what
um
this guy christopher torres
look at this it's a full on exposed
video on
martin
sommolier exposed tap water once
filtered we're serious yeah yeah let's
check it out what well martin's taking
it seriously he thinks it's a hit job
from some water company
i'm serious possible
i'm
that water has a tds level this stands
for total dissolved solids how many mils
actually combine in the water and there
is no
pure water and i i go always crazy when
people say oh yeah water needs to be
pure
and then you're calling suddenly a
purified water and no no it's the best
you can drink because pure needs to be
pure that doesn't come from other nature
it's a
processed
processed food
this kind of bottled water where it
belongs is the trash can i trash it
big water is coming from way more
electrolytes than every single purified
water so i have to choose between
purified and latex i would
so that apparently
[Music]
that's what he's getting called out for
he goes yo
exposing water smelly martin he said
he'd rather drink l.a tap over bottled
water so
that was the whole video that's it man
they didn't come with any receipts about
like la tap water why it would be bad
well martin responded to
um that was it
terrible exposed video
well i don't know i mean i i kind of i
was like
kind of got him there
got him
how did he get him i don't know i just i
love him
he would rather drink the la tap water
than dishonest or what i just love the
idea i think i'd agree
yeah i mean his point was was well made
you know
but i love that uh there's water somalia
wars and listen he has a whole
conspiracy about it let's listen
i have to choose between purified and
latex i would go for elite
hold the horses the kangen sales people
think they can expose me
who's the king who's kangan i yeah cause
he called them out kangan sales people
are coming for him he says
yo big water does not like martin i'll
be honest with you
kangan water purifier smart water has
their stock price half since martin's
been speaking out against interesting
kangen water alkalize ionic water kind
of oh that's just the name of water
kangan yeah the king and people are
coming for martin what are we gonna do
about it
by saying that i said i would prefer
ali tap over purified water
guess what my friends i'm saying this
since 15 years because i don't believe
that you should go to a store and buy
tap water processed tap water in a
plastic bottle and by the way it's
sommelier not so whatever you're trying
to say there cheers my friends and
remember water is not just water dude
dishing out martin had absolutely
dispatched these haters
[ __ ] hell
what a guy
people saying wait people are calling
the kagan thing
mlm
it's a water multi-level pyramid scheme
there's a bunch of people saying this so
wait wait kangan
mlm dude what kangan water a scam mlm or
pyramid scheme look at this
how do you
damn that's crazy bro
water
pyramid scheme
that's incredible post about
um anti-mlm
a subreddit pull it up
damning people oh i'm just
all right whatever nice alcoholic water
is a wealthy person's mlm
it is like most mlm based on [ __ ]
pseudoscience preying on people with
health issues wow okay
this isn't my first rodeo well do they
make like crazy health claims about it
well here
here's a uh a totally impartial
debunking kangen
water pyramid
or scam it is not a pyramid scheme says
kangenwater.com
1412.com yeah
um
so that seems pretty thoroughly debunked
there
kagan oh it's a machine
yep
god well you can retire better
wait benefits let's see what kind of
crazy ass claims they make it helps
clean the body
okay that's already sounds super well
that's true of all water
it's supposed that's true yeah that's
true yeah shut out water
it helps clean the body while providing
balance to the immune system
water
kangen water also burns fat
and fights against the effects of aging
yo how do they how do they claim this
[ __ ] that's like well if you don't have
water you'll age real quick age right
into the grave right you'll die yeah
many people report that the daily use of
this water also helps the digestive
system are they literally called a
miracle our miracle water generator
removes the impurities and chlorine from
tap water well that's that that's what
all
water filters do
wow that's so interesting martin opened
up a whole nother world for me
the kangan people
see how happy he is man if you bro if
you got some kagan you'd be
smiling like this too
you know what that smile says
he's it says i've got ten thousand
dollars of kagan in my garage that i
gotta sell to all my friends or i'm
going bankrupt
but he's got lots of time because
thankfully he'll live forever thanks to
this miracle water look at that yes
pagan saved this man
whoa that's so crazy dude
people are nuts man
there it is
well i'd love to get i'd love to talk to
martin and get the dirt on the kagan
people yeah
um
also we have an update from the giant
slide
i love all these videos this is the uh
out of control slide in detroit
that av told us about
or we talked about anyway
let's go
[Laughter]
[Music]
i wonder does anyone get really
seriously injured they must be like
broken
i was
but like there's got to be broken bones
concussions
we got to get you down this slide
i'll do a weekend trip i'd do it we got
to get your ass back to detroit man
i want to see your ass go down that i'll
wear a gopro too oh fun okay fun
[Applause]
[Music]
this is so interesting
the spine buster
kind of a dope beat that's true
i feel like you could sample that
i can try and flip it
right
there's already a song about that
all right let's get that
let's get to our first we have a couple
stories main stories here
this addison wraith story is getting so
weird bro with young gravy
we've talked about how her dad
was
macking on or dating well i don't even
remember
a young
like 18 year old
or 20 year old or something
keemstar vibes right yes
and um
and then young gravy was making
he's this rapper was making jokes about
how he's interested in addison ray's mom
and it's so hard to tell what's real
what's not
i personally thought the young gravy
wanting to sleep with mom's things was
just a goof
but here he is bringing addison ray's
mom to the va
of vmas
as his date and just what i mean
[Music]
[Applause]
all right sorry quick update
pokemans in chat she said ain't no way
the channel is going to get deleted
before i'm on hell nah girl that's true
no way bro we will not let that happen
we'll be very careful this week we will
watch ethan like a hawk
no death threats this week until until
next week i'll hold off all day we'll
wait until you're on terroristic dress
and then death to the world
yes so pokey what do you what you're
making on this you think this shit's
real or not
so here they are
that wasn't actually the one that
freaked me out it was this one
of them kissing at the red carpet
i mean
i mean
has this just gone too far
addison rey's mom is making out
with young gravy at the
vmas it's mommy makeout day her dad is
running a muck
trying to pick up young girls making
that [ __ ] insane video
challenging young gravy to a fight
is addison ray's life really this [ __ ]
or is this all some weird elaborate
social ploy
i don't know
i think
addison
i hope that her friends are being extra
nice to her right now okay i have an
update from pokemane yeah that i think
gravy is down to hit but doesn't want a
relationship plus she makes
oh she likes the revenge it gets on her
ex-husband
so gravy's trying to hit and quit
his mom
that's an interesting analysis but like
you would think that this poor girl's
parent
i mean christ i mean
people please
just [ __ ]
well was there more to this
why are they doing this to her the the
mom making out with young gravy was
there was there more than just them they
were flirting right i mean olivia you
probably know best yes um
they were
so
young gravy posted on his tick tock
calling out for milfs and addison rey's
mother uh sherry responded
it was funny it was cool we young gravy
responded it was funny it was cool then
monty responded in a way that was
dramatic and scary for the rest of the
world and young gravy and addison and
jerry i'm sure
and then we've covered
thus far
and so now they're on the car it sounds
like the dad is the real issue here why
would the mom i mean dude you've already
got one psycho parent obviously poor
addison ray who's embarrassing her
bringing shame to the family now why is
the mom
yeah gotta go out and do this like i'm
sorry feels like she's like rubbing salt
in like addison's wound if there's a
wound it's just to us it seems like
there is think about the daughter man
yeah i know you're trying to get some
strange dick and young gravy you're
trying to get that gravy
and gravy like that gravy a lot of the
chat agrees with pokey who said it's
mutually beneficial but not an actual
relationship you know how what does it
really benefit the mom though i'm just
confused like i mean she know it's going
to humiliate her daughter it's just so
wild this is your mother i've heard
about her i mean i know about her now
because you think she's trying to get
clout her mom
yeah parlay
well addison doesn't follow either monty
or sherry anyway so
does sherry have like a social media
yeah okay i got to see that yeah i got
to see this we watched her tick tock of
her doing the whop i got oh my god
please god how are these people real i
gotta see this
i gotta send me monty and shari's
daughters
god these people what are they doing
when the wap dance came out that's when
sherry like
i think a fan base broke out for her oh
god
here let me send it okay so here's
oh god her okay i'm sorry this changes
everything her mom is a bagel oh [ __ ] me
in that tits bro
14 million followers yeah she's kind of
she's an influencer in her own right
okay this changes everything this
changes everything
all of her tick tocks have like five
million
blushes
oh here here's one with young gravy
and
tana
yes
oh [ __ ]
can we listen this one or no
it's gravy song
okay
oh she's pretending to be upset
so there was some
[Music]
okay i can see this being a goof between
them now yeah
i didn't know that she was this
this social media superstar
it was the kissing that i was like oh
whoa whoa
for real it was just a peck though at
the same time but maybe
maybe um
maybe pokey's right maybe maybe he's
down to hit and quit hermione quit and
quit
hey guys mother of christ
let's see
uh
here
is can we get some
no
oh it's just a family vlog no i don't
want to watch that because they they
click baited me olivia sent the best one
that's the uh
the whop okay here it is
she broke the internet with this
i'll be honest though it is impressive
right for an old lady or i don't know
how old she's probably in her late 40s
she's 42. she's 42. oh my god two years
older than you ethan
she's 42. yeah
see i don't
she's 42. she's doing her thing i don't
know i don't really see this as being
that bad like the dad is is embarrassing
as [ __ ] but i haven't seen anything yet
but she
am i crazy thinking she looks way older
than me
um
yeah
yeah i think she looks way older than me
and i know
not to [ __ ] not to shame her she's
beautiful obviously
hold that thought pokemon says i do feel
bad for edison though and loki hope her
and her mom at least have spoken about
this okay her dad seems too far gone
yeah
it is i worry about that poor girl
because she's like she's minding her own
business she's having she's like cool i
made it i've got this great career
and then both of her parents want to get
in the limelight and like take attention
away from her yeah
holy [ __ ]
you have uh
gp
gp collagen i remember like when she
first started on tick tock she so like
so willingly
had them in her videos like she would
just dance with her family they'd have
fun so it just like it makes me i don't
know if
if it bothers her or not but
i feel bad if it does gp coming at you
can you imagine if my parent well my mom
is trying to be an influencer let's be
honest yeah i would lose my if she did a
whap maybe she'd get some followers but
right now she just talks about
butterflies no that's a segment
of
i don't think my mom could survive a
whopping she got a pacemaker
right but she'll have gary do it am i
i'm sorry to say this i really again i
don't mean any disrespect to her but
does she doesn't she look older than me
frank
i think she looks we know we're young
loki yeah i don't know if she was 50 she
was young looking old man and i'm sorry
i really don't mean to be offensive i'm
just shocked that she's
i i see what you mean i'll say this
you look very young for yourself she's
fun you know what five years older than
me
you're the first person that said ever
said that maybe well you do it's just
your hair that's the only reason people
say that you think i look young for my
age yeah definitely it's just your hair
that's the only seven you have the
airline
18 year old
that's true wait how old are you a.b i'm
30.
you look really young i do look really
young though yeah i do
look how youthful i look guys
wait so how old is this
just so you know
every time you look at that hairline i
want you to know
i pointed that out to you
what that you have a god-like hair do
you think i didn't know that airline
no no no it wasn't a thing it's like you
think i didn't know that you didn't know
that
yeah i knew i knew i had a good hairline
you know you had a good baby you got a
good hairline maybe you created the meme
not everyone's young and healthy
wait wait so so
i might i don't again i'm not trying to
be a dick i'm just
maybe i i'm wounded by by i'm thinking
that we're she's like a dating range to
me
like if i was single
i assumed she was 50 plus i'm that
that's why i don't want to be mean i'm
sorry but i see what you mean and yeah i
don't want to be obviously she's
beautiful and healthy and god bless her
about everything
i just can't believe she's 42. that's
crazy so addison's got to be like 19 or
something she's 21. 21. so she had a
real real young sorry
beautiful i guess at 21. right that's
the only way this dude monty became a
dad
monty's her stepdad oh monty's her
stepdad
she was very young when they got married
but yes
a stepdad energy stepdad energy
is her dad out of the picture you know a
lot of edison raylor
she's rt expert what's my what's my job
yeah
i consume everything
so wait that that the real dad is just
gone or the biological dad let's say
i'm pretty positive
yes and then monty came in i think monty
when she was four
i might have to double check that but
then addison's brother is monty's
father i mean addison's whoa
addison's brother is monty's son
right yes his so she has a half brother
so it's pretty they have they were they
have a nuclear family it's not really
stepdad vibes
and then when did they get divorced
who sherry and monty yeah like a few
months ago what the hell
like very recently and we got
on the show
i would love that can we please get
addison ray on the show um
gravy tweeted this morning um
commenting on someone had reposted the
video of them kissing and he said like
just let her live her single life she's
new and single and having fun
and so that was the newest
story gravy oh gravy
that's what i'm saying gravy no i listen
listen
i thought she was older
she's 42.
wait give me some audio this is still
her daughter's world
oh my god in america i'm looking to make
some whoopee you feel me trying to
butter the biscuit
oh my god
people are saying monty's her real dad
but that's not what i
i'm back in america
wow so this flirtation's been going on
isn't isn't monty's new girlfriend super
young and she's like a major drama yeah
yeah isn't she in so much drama too
she's the girl
i'm saying that it is her real dad i
guess the mix-up was that they they
broke up at one point when they were
younger and then remarried again
to each other so
okay so he is the real dad okay he is
the father the father unfortunately the
father i apologize
so who's the this is so much wrong
okay first of all addison
you got to come on the show
we're the premier podcast go to the
podcast tab on youtube you'll see it
number one first one there first one
there pops right up this is the place to
do it come on
so
so tell me more about monty's new
girlfriend
she um she started the rumor that uh
kanye and jeffrey star were uh hooking
up which we talked about a long time ago
yeah she licked the toilet seat okay
show me that give me that oh wait i
think you get banned for showing that
one
i don't know she was
she got in a lot of trouble i think you
guys might remember this video it was a
influencer
in a bathroom on an airplane and she was
licking the toilet seat
why
shh
to show that she wasn't afraid to covet
or something yep she was on spring break
ow
that's the best challenge that somebody
made up
lick the toilet seat challenge that's
disgusting
didn't you take the challenge
bro
[Music]
what'd you say uh love
didn't she even make the challenge
i think she was the first and last
person to do that challenge and how old
is
he's 46 according to google
and she is 25 i think i just saw
i will say some outlets call him her
stepdad so it's not just me
but
i guess so we might have to switch up if
if that's wrong also
[Music]
good we have in the docs screenshots
that were shared i guess gravy and ava
were talking
and i think gravy was interested in a
louisiana that is true too oh we have
like actual dude this is so wild
here is
uh monty
responding
no shot [ __ ]
monty's leaving comments on instagram
unbothered thank you on gravy for taking
the leftovers
this man is literally saying
leftovers you can't be serious
this is the trashiest [ __ ] dude that
ever lived this dude is a toilet seat
[Music]
w cam
i would rather spend time with my
daughter
and two grandkids then sherry nicole
made me abandon
that sherry cole made me abandon as a
child
in order to be whoa
whoa whoa whoa
i would rather spend time with my
daughter
and two grandkids that sherry nicole
made me abandon
as a child
in order to be with her
what
never let our ears to this
never let a woman make you choose
between her
and or your blood child you know what
dan
a milf is like an onion
there's layers
a milf is like an onion
[Laughter]
that's true i mean they've been through
a lot
that milf gaming ain't easy man it's not
easy that milf game
there's a lot of landmines ethan yeah
this is a small side note we should
finish talking about this oh [ __ ] here
she is but martin is on standby
oh my god i'm texting with him he said
um he's always there for us and then he
said family
all right so let me finish this segment
we'll talk about addison and then maybe
we can loot back to martin i'd love to
chat with martin all right so wow dude
and then addison's just stuck in the
middle so she unfollowed them both so it
must really be affecting her obviously
um
bruh and then so gravy responded
this was the video he made that was just
super weird
[Music]
you guys remember that probably
i'm a grown man i'm not gonna fight you
over tick tock drama
you got one of the most successful
daughters in the world and
you decide to act half her age to try to
get some attention
while embarrassing your whole family so
grow up
get some help and if we cross paths from
your life don't do anything stupid
this is real
i thought this [ __ ] was all sht this is
[ __ ] real beef yeah bro this is too
much for me to deal with
holy [ __ ] i thought my parents were
were annoying
it's not easy this is new levels of that
[ __ ]
they just divorced like six months ago
and all hell is breaking loose
how do we get to addison we need her
bestie addison
we are all addison's besties today
you go reach out olivia
what's the best way to get a hold of her
i wonder she's so like famous though
it's hard probably i feel like you
probably right just
i don't know it probably doesn't follow
me i'll
we'll talk about after the show try to
figure out a way to do it
here's is monty's new girlfriend
the coronavirus challenge
i'm not going to play it because
it might get us in trouble
but
let me just find the
this is his uh
well you just played the most important
part there and well there it is
is this covid related
this is monty's uh
dreamboat
it's awesome but chad is saying he seems
fun ask hannah for the addison anna of
course your bestie truth is that's your
best friend
addison is in israel
i got israel
what are your connections wait what's
she doing in israel she's a singer and
all that right does she sing the jews
yeah singer actress
[Laughter]
all right this is a lot guys i don't
know if i could this this
my head is spinning from this all being
real
gravy's been talking
apparently here's text messages that
were shared
who shared these
i believe it was ava
she sent pictures of her and monty
together
is ava her mom
no it was his current girlfriend the the
toilet liquor the toilet licker yeah
that's april
that's okay wait that's my auntie's
girlfriend is texting gravy they i guess
gravy was interested in ava at some
point in time pretty recently yeah
i'm in hoboken so like 10 minutes away
i'm around till thursday but tonight and
tuesday are free for me well tonight
around midnight i'm free if you want to
get ticked down is that what
shout out gravy i guess at least he's
straightforward right i mean
what a gentleman if would you prefer
ladies
ladies would you prefer to be
communicated directly with that or uh
beat around the bush
she sorry beating around the bush is
what he was trying to do she's in israel
her boyfriend is a israeli record
producer
oh [ __ ]
her boyfriend probably got mob ties and
[ __ ]
probably a dangerous dude
maybe don't say that if you're trying to
get her to come on this show
yeah i don't think she's going to
the israelis no i don't think i love the
israelis i lived there come on i mean uh
hey baruch hashem
uh
all that [ __ ]
you know bro hashem
dick down tonight
i mean i could tonight probably a little
earlier tuesday tonight i'll get to my
hotel around midnight gotta be up at
like eight but i'll be gucci
it goes on
i'm in la she says flying back tonight
babe
what
what's
what the [ __ ]
what's the time is this the next day
so she
she's with monty
while talking about sleeping with gravy
i'm not as familiar as a timeline sec
i assume yes
i guys what the [ __ ] is this
she's a drama stir man she just stirs
the pot
and then she posted the text so she's
just a lame-o yeah she she's notorious
for starting [ __ ] after
she looked at toilet seat no she started
the whole jeffree star kanye rumors
yeah there's a tick tock video that she
posted after the jeffree star
kanye thing where she was like it's not
true i wanted to be famous
loved that for another honest queen
dick down
i wanted to be famous i love the honesty
you're a dick writer
that's amazing though i didn't know
people actually just are that
straightforward are you trying to get
dick down tonight
that's uh i like that you know he
doesn't feel he's like yo
this is my intention straight forward
these are this is my intention with you
right
i don't know
but you got to imagine he's texting like
10 other girls that same [ __ ] right
i'm dick tip you trying to get [ __ ]
down tonight girl um
imagine talking like that [ __ ] nobody no
one would ever speak to me if i talked
like that young
gravy it's good to be famous i guess
if i ever texted a girl you want you're
trying to get [ __ ] down tonight i'd be
blocked immediately
i would never speak there again i'll
never see you again
holy [ __ ] so so now what's this what is
monty's
who's this [ __ ] that's a tick tock that
monty posted to them
[Music]
laker something kissing is that the girl
that's able to eat yes
oh my god where are you bro why are they
in like a fema center
[Laughter]
they're giving blood man is he like the
celebrity at this like high
school is that he's at the high school
man
i cannot believe what i'm seeing man
this is really too much
oh my god you guys this is a lot
you trying to get [ __ ] down tonight
girl or not people on the chat saying
text ela that right now and see what
happens all right
that's funny maybe hopefully he was not
watching you should all text your
partners that
see what happens oh that's a well lena
unfortunately
come on man you just you just see me
i'll come back everyone knows she's
right now there's there's no doubt
there's no dick downing tonight her her
sister and her friend are staying with
us so yeah it's just small the logistics
don't work
i get it but wait are you guys have your
own room right no no they have a studio
yep
you got a divider though a sleeping
arrangement
we gave them our bed
and our couches both fold out to queen
beds in the living room they probably
wouldn't notice
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding i
don't want to try it i will say they
would
just a joke don't try that please your
sister for christ's sake shame on you
it's disgusting
all right i'm going to text you though
are you ready she's going to know i'm
[ __ ] with her are you ready to get
[ __ ]
anyone else want to do this challenge
with me
are you ready to get [ __ ] down tonight
no [ __ ]
is that did i say it right are you ready
to get dick down tonight yeah all right
i'm messaging ally arena if you want to
put some like cheesy uh emojis in there
with like the
the eggplant or the squirt [ __ ] i
want to keep it as believable as
possible so so true yeah just clean
are you ready to get [ __ ] down tonight
to the point she's the next door she's
probably coming here be like the [ __ ]
are you okay
so you did it dan yeah zach you want to
take the challenge
sure
[Applause]
sam is here so that one doesn't work
either
[Music]
shame
kim you got anyone people in the chat
saying they're texting their significant
others so
we got a lot of feel free to participate
everybody
there's never been so many dick down
texts sent that one
the text heard around the world
no response from her
you're a dick rider you're a dick sucker
hop off my [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'll let you guys know if i hear i might
not get a reply for a while
this is going to be an interesting
experiment yeah
i'll keep you posted
i'm praying for you
yeah i had somebody i just texted my
husband
keep ahead
wait so what does a woman say were you
ready to get
i guess down still works oh she did yeah
let's see what she wrote i got a
response
she sent me
she sent me a gift of somebody looking
suspiciously with yeah eyes
yeah she's too she knows she knows
something's up yeah she knows
i'm waiting for aila
all right
someone said they sent it to their
grandma
that'll be interesting
well apollo us my deepest condolences
addison ray
this whole thing is
i don't think we've ever seen anything
like it on the internet
what what's your thought on young gravy
getting tangled up in all this
business-wise or
i mean that's his that's his thing he's
like the milf hunter i think it's
pretty genius
it's yeah i agree
he's not doing anything wrong right he's
doing everything right i think like even
his early songs are about
chasing elves going after melves yeah
and that's another thing like is like
that's a funny shtick to have for a
young guy but yeah is he really the male
hunter i think i'm just not that old i
just hope when he's texting her he's a
little bit less up front like instead of
like
he'd be more polite yeah like not get
[ __ ] down but maybe perhaps i could
spread your cheeks or something or yeah
ma'am may i please
please sit on my face
would you like to tate would you like to
take a seat on my face tonight darling
i thank you by the way for the color or
the teddy fresh uh squatty potty stool
oh bone fork we like we're gonna be
sending so fast he is
straight into production
let me see hila where are you come on
hello i'll be like hello
are you ready to get down dick down
tonight yes or no [ __ ] you
okay
that was a whole journey
here's another journey
fouseytube
keemstar's partner
before we go to another store do you
want to get martin in here oh [ __ ] he
was standing by can we ask martin what
do you think some mills
no no let's not just
keep it respectful i'm just kidding
keeping hello
i
don't be the victim here you can make
jokes just don't don't say that [ __ ]
about martin yeah make them be funny
yeah maybe
he's a sommelier okay
did ila tell you no she didn't respond
i can't believe he has a 01 visa for
walker it's crazy
it's like oscars level uh visa you need
an oscars to get the visa
he is nobody he really is an expert in
his field i gotta say
yeah it's impressive
um
so we are getting martin on the phone i
want to talk about his water drama yo
did you just make this cam
yeah that's awesome
thank you
so we're gonna be asking martin about
this water drama oh martin
the water sommelier that's a good that
i'm watching
the last water
his whole style is like a avatar
character too you know and he is the
only water smelly so he is the last
water smallier it's true
all right uh he's in the lobby let me uh
again so
for those of you don't know martin is a
water expert we brought him on i was
very skeptical and he changed all of us
the man is a genius
he's a real he's the real deal martin
joining us today
lovely to see you martin can you hear me
hello hello yeah sure i can hear you
welcome
how are ya first of all i just want you
to know
martin
that i speak for me and everybody except
a b here that we have great reverence
for you i don't know if you were
watching but abe was suggesting to say
something very uncouth to you and i just
want to know that i don't support that
what do you want to
he wanted to ask you if you if you what
do you think about milfs
i like them you like thank you thank you
thank you thank you
legend who doesn't enjoy some
you know thank you from well-trained
age like fine wine beautiful lady like
what like you you don't you want water
that spent its time collecting minerals
and gathering flavor like i'm not here
we go
here we go i like it wet you know okay
there it is
and there it is
so martin a lot's happening in your life
first of all
i is this a real is someone really
trying to expose you on tick tock what's
going on there hilarious god i it's for
me the best thing ever i love this
kangan people because they are the best
ever because it's free
content creation for me they're making
these crazy videos and then i just have
to literally like stitch them and make
videos of them and it's too much fun
it's too much fun
so the kagan people which we learned a
bit about
it's like a multi-level marketing where
they sell a machine that apparently
creates some super water that like heals
all your problems and so the cake and
people are really after you martin oh
yeah they love me and they are all
they're trying their best and all every
week i'm getting an email or like like
an exposed video or something from them
and then they're saying martin is so
wrong and he wants to sell you all this
poison water and you're going to be dead
when you're drinking a carbonated water
for example it is hilarious guys they
are too much fun to make fun of so
you've been making lots of videos
calling out the kagan the kagan the
kegels
penguin
the kangan people and so
wow oh that's so interesting that you're
in a water wars here at the moment
but i think it's fun because let's face
it there's so many people out there who
believe that [ __ ]
so for me it's very important to always
go to the facts and the videos i'm doing
then i'm always sending them in my posts
the links or the screenshots of the
scientific facts actually because
they're just saying some crazy [ __ ]
without any claims and i'm putting then
obviously what i do and they debunked
them i put in the claims and right in my
videos they can really see what's going
on but funny that you just said this did
you heard about the new show on netflix
selling the oc
like yeah
yeah so this one girl
said who's on selling those see her name
is alessandra said she's another life
awards family
what and i don't know how many how many
taxes i got now
martin did you saw this did you saw this
saying she used to be a water so you
want to be a water somebody so i just
posted literally for 10 minutes ago a
new video on instagram and tick tock
where i kind of like debunked her
[ __ ] as well oh what a [ __ ] liar
in water sommelier that's blasphemy bro
what are we gonna do about it exactly
that i said that so you should watch
that so someone pull it up a bit my god
by the way the water i had at the
italian restaurant was fantastic it was
oh my god
micro bubbles natural occurring it's a
natural cream it's so nice
it was so nice we had two bottles of
those
the funny thing is i watched that video
and i said it to my wife because my wife
actually runs the hotel where that
restaurant is located
right away to her manager so that's
great i love that video oh that's cool
yeah there's a really nice hotel we that
was my first time at that
at the uh mario's or madeos yeah monday
oh yeah
so here is selling oc a fake water
sommelier
now
martin are you ever concerned for your
safety you're messing with big water and
they might come for you like they might
follow you they might think you're a
threat they might take you out martin
yeah look i i received already some
legal letters from some big water
companies and it's always interesting
and fun to get this kind of letters but
i have to say i'm doing it for the
people i'm doing it for the family
and i want to expose this [ __ ] what
you see on marketing and the internet
and my wife is actually a little
concerned because you never know there's
some crazy people out there big water is
a big business
but i feel okay i will call you up when
i need security yeah definitely let me
know i don't wanna they're gonna drown
you in a pool of like uh
[Laughter]
a fate worse than death okay so here is
this fake ass
thank you
but why are you using ice cubes and
lemon in your water because the ice
cubes are made of a different water so
they will water down the water with
water
and your slice of lemon will literally
like neutralize all flavors out of maybe
the water would have in the first place
so we're against lemon and water
i think like when you want to do it
just for enjoyment do it but
automatically ice cubes and lemons has
absolutely no go and actually good
restaurants they would never do that
it'll destroy the water yeah it's like
when you when you're buying your bottle
of flour well for example what you did
in the restaurant on friday and they put
right away your lemon ice cubes in there
you will not taste anything out of this
water anymore so why even bring this
over from italy in the first place that
doesn't make sense
right that's true i mean we didn't have
ice or lemon in our cups you're right
that's more for like tap water right to
mask the flavor of
crying correct but don't do it so she's
a fraud she doesn't know [ __ ] about
water no now let's see what she's doing
now okay let's see what you're up to
that's a no go for water somebody i
actually have a water machine at home
that is alkaline oh please oxygenated oh
my god yeah and microcosm don't say i'm
not even sure what that means
but it apparently like keeps the
molecules small yeah so you don't blow
and you drink water okay
is she trying to sell keegan machines
right now yeah it's she's hanging out
she's doing her market multi-market
level
mlm [ __ ] on the netflix
crazy
whoa
around like six grand so my humble
opinion that's your personal waters for
me
alkaline water
doesn't make any sense for your body
because everything what you're drinking
will go acidic in your very highly
acidic stomach
second oxygenated water
you're not a fish you cannot access
oxygen
dissolved in water that's really
nonsense
and micro clustered water
is literally a term used in a water scan
people will splurge six grand on a
handbag why can't i you know spend six
grand on is this an ad i'm confused did
keegan pay them to put this in it's like
i have no clue it's crazy
that is the problem with multi-level
marketing so what kangan does and they
are like very tricky on the home picture
of kangan they don't do any health
claims nothing it's just this small
distributors who are doing all this
nonsense so when somebody gets sued they
can always say oh it's just this person
who tried to sell it but it's not us as
a company it's so wrong and it's like a
racket it's like it's like mafia [ __ ]
dear alexandra i have a feeling you have
been scammed by a multi-level marketing
company who sold you an overpriced
ionizing machine
without any scientific backups a water
source is doing exactly the opposite
a water somewhere you will bring
attention to this kind of scammers and
will debunk them so
there's a long way to go but hey
i'm happy to teach you and happy to
showcase you how important water is how
well your water is and that we all need
to start to rethink
it is interesting you're the only guy
out there there's a huge water scam
going on and nobody's talking about it
you're the one guy who's taking the
whole big water on you're taking on the
ocean bro hey somebody has to do it
somebody asked what does martin think of
water filters like brita i think you
said they're good right for tap water
absolutely yeah and that's the reason
that's always my point i'm not against
purifying water at home i'm against to
bite water in a [ __ ] store they're
selling back the water to you and
they're glorifying tap water and selling
it with a fake marketing story and that
is the real [ __ ]
also they says have you ever heard of
liquid death i know you've spoke of it
you said it's a good water right liquid
there yeah it's a great water from the
austrian art cessation of 107 yes way
more electrolyte than a smart ward in
accenture combined
rory says the mole thank you for the
dono rory thank you verdono the mole
people have decided to find and destroy
your enemies martin so rory says the
mole people are on your side
thank you
where are you seated right now martin
what room are you in yeah it's kind of
cool i'm in spring place it's a private
business club here in beverly hills i
run this because i kind of just live
from water and love and mills so i need
to
i need to
walk a little bit as well huh wait what
what is that place
it's called spring place it's a private
business club in beverly hills a private
business club what does that mean
it's like co-working space it's kind of
like a oh like a hybrid of soul house
and we works oh oh okay okay cool
that's your day job etched and
everything it's pretty cool it's awesome
it's a nice place nice wow well there
you go guys if you're uh
save your money on keegan's and go
rent a room for martin's
uh
what are you
by the way on saturday this week we had
a big water tasting competition i had to
drink 80 different mineral waters in an
hour how many do you get right
you cannot believe i needed to go so
badly to the restroom i was like almost
in pain
after after 80 80 waters well i didn't
get them right or wrong like it was
blind tasting and i gave them like
scores oh what do you think what pretty
good and what is really not so good in
in a water from a taste perspective so
it's pretty cool
some really awesome new water so i'm
happy to bring them over next time you
might be inviting me to the show and i'm
going to hydrate you again was there any
surprising results from the blind taste
test there was one water from us and
from austria it's called geisberg
i never heard about this water i was
blown away from a taste perspective but
still water was super fruity
it was like what the hell is this and
like everybody we were like six dig for
water summer yes and we were all in this
line and suddenly i was like what the
hell is this for a flavor it was insane
iceberg i gave them 100 iceberg
geissberg water i like guys
all right martin
you do the good fight out there don't
let these water uh goons get to you okay
we got your back
we got your back you just tell us who to
drown
yeah i love this i got the water already
ready for you yeah of course
all right
and we'll do them the pleasure we'll
drown him in natural spring water we can
do at least absolutely
we're doing it in style yeah yeah
martin do you plan when you pass away
are we throwing you in are your ashes
into a freshwater lake are you being
cremated uh do we have some water plants
in the actually when you die i just
talked with my wife about it because you
never know how one day never know
and and we decided when when she passed
as well and then all the money what
maybe hopefully i still have and i
didn't drunk it by just water i want to
actually be put into the ocean like ash
into the ocean and then all my
financials goes to
goes to viva con aqua it's a non-profit
organization out of germany
for water right so the ocean back to the
water from whence you came yeah very
let's see all right martin just like bin
laden just like bin laden thank you dan
what a what a nice what a nice thought
from dan
you'll share a tomb with bin laden
energy in the ocean obviously
he's got to balance it out yeah
absolutely
all right martin we love you keep
fighting the good fight all right
cheers my friends
kagans [ __ ] yes
all right take care thank you bye-bye
guys love you
man actually i have a text from ela oh
oh
so i said are you ready to get dick down
tonight she said
why
and then a minute later she said what
but she said w
ut like what
sounds like she wasn't totally against
it
no she i i said i should i respond and
say i said are you ready
[Laughter]
i said i'm putting in all caps are you
ready
[Music]
are
you ready
[Music]
and tonight
so now i i'm re-emphasizing
[Music]
i said
are you ready to get [ __ ] down tonight
in all caps
exclamation question mark
sex so
everyone's saying dude she's so ready
she's so into you bro what why you bro
that's what they say when they're so
ready yeah exactly i said did i say what
what
i must say that i've had some
post-coital regrets about it wasn't no
no it wasn't no
wasn't yes though either
true correct
[Laughter]
what a treat to have martin call in it's
always a pleasure yeah
yeah
one of a kind that guy
great guy he's a treasure he really is
um
love is jealous of about of the visa he
got
actually yes very curious it's it is
incredible he got a
visa for exceptional people i mean
that's fantastic
was like one-of-a-kind yeah go ahead
look
yeah it's like noble prize type [ __ ] we
talked to a lawyer and she said now you
can't get that visa only for uh oscar
winning actors noble price top of the
field
yeah you have to have like articles
written about you you have to be like oh
yeah have public international
recognition what about what about us
we could give we could issue love and
honorary steamy this year and then maybe
he would qualify okay yeah we could
probably engineer something to defraud
the government yeah yeah maybe like buy
a couple articles yeah right maybe let's
talk about it
yeah yeah
love you're my office bff so you win
that to me that's wonderful thank you
that's more important than it is
yeah thank you you get used to everyone
just for that dude
yeah i should
thank you very much well we would need
to manufacture some
some achievement or something like that
you uh discovered nra
you know do you remember when they the
college admissions scandal they like
photoshopped their daughter onto like a
kayaker's face
yeah
yeah yeah yeah well i am only like on a
real note though i'm so surprised it's
so hard to get a visa holy moly
yeah it is it's always
to my understanding it's always been
really hard to get a visa well the most
most people just get married then it's
easy you know right right right we have
great laws about like having kids here
or automatically citizens you get
married you can bring the whole family
over
right yeah
[Music]
oh well so i don't know why are you
currently looking i mean i think
marriage is a good route for you
yeah
uh well maybe you know you never know i
i'm only looking for real love of course
dude you should put on you should just
log into tinder
and then you can set your your zip code
to like l.a oh i see yeah you like milfs
love
i mean for a visa [ __ ] she you like
guild [ __ ]
for a visa you know anything goes i'm
not gonna lie a dilf olivia's grandma
was pretty down to clone
true same true true i don't know if i
could take it she's a treat
we just gotta try harder buddy there's
always a way
yeah just ask any israeli here they're
all [ __ ] schemers none of those guys
yeah i'm like legit
it's crazy
it's true maybe i'll just go win that
nobel prize instead i don't know
[Music]
yeah i don't think i've never met an
israeli except my my wife
who actually came here like the way
you're supposed to come
so like no i
i i said that he worked for my business
and he's my uncle and
i married someone
it's all so shady but i love it hey
there's a you you gotta you gotta find a
way to do get over here yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'll look into that thank you
uh the letter a gave a hundred dollars
said i will marry love for a visa please
can we get pictures
[Music]
a
a i forgot to put the b
[Laughter]
no uh thank you for the gifted
today was my first day teaching
of the school year if you all had any
words of advice perspective
encouragement it would mean the world
i followed the pod since i was a minimum
wage
worker at a gas station so your first
day teaching
whoa i don't know man
it depends what grade you teach just
don't let those little [ __ ] get to
you dude
you got to hold your head up man yeah
you got to hold your head up don't want
to walk over maintain your integrity
don't take any [ __ ] from those your
first day in there the best advice i can
give is your first day you got to take
you got to take one of the the bigger
kids
and you just got to beat the [ __ ] out of
them in front of all the other ones
punching kind of established
[ __ ] yeah you can't you can't let the
others know that you know you're weak so
no you got to let them know you're
always a threat yeah my um my aunt is a
kindergarten teacher for lausd and i was
talking to her a few days ago and i'm
like you know how's it going teaching
kindergarten she's all it's good except
this one kid this kid is like biting
children in the class
and it's apparently it's just a
nightmare to be dealing with
so
she tried biting yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean that's what you
gotta do yeah yeah
i don't know about it but yeah just keep
you know keep be yourself bro just
[ __ ] and if you need to punch a kid
just do it man
just worry just make sure no one has
those they're recording it
katie said i love i was granted a 01 and
have a great lawyer now i'm an emmy
winner and upgraded to a green card what
bro who's this katie halliday has an
emmy who is that would be happy to try
and help you out
even if it's just a recommendation
letter
who is quick well
that's crazy wait who is katie halliday
she's an emmy
yo this girl says should i dm him on
instagram my name is eileen and i'm
willing and ready
that's
[Music]
this is legit i mean if that's unless
there's another uh katy holiday
i found her instagram
she followed eileen or
katie she follows us
oh my god dude
it's cool shout the [ __ ] out you're way
too talented and successful to be
watching this way too bad what are you
doing here you should be watching like
uh that's what what jabonsky i'm always
like dude you're way too all right yeah
guy jablonski he's like a super
accomplished uh music
you responded are you [ __ ] kidding me
she said yes daddy
yes i swear to god i love you she said
yes daddy
okay
[Music]
w ethan w ethan yes
should i just put crabs in the chat or
what dan how do i draw that crabs no
that's like crabs
send the squash emoji who is my daddy
squash
yeah you should say to eggplant eggplant
yeah let's kick it up a notch i'm
embarrassed i even know how to handle
this energy now
daddy
[ __ ]
yes daddy okay
[Music]
gonna need a minute
thank you
see some titties
there it is
there it is everyone
did it
she does not call me daddy for the
record
actually she does because we have kids
so she calls me dad not daddy and i call
her mom come on
daddy tonight is daddy come
come
[Music]
what the [ __ ] were you talking about
before ela
uh i love a visa
yo that that so
um milk great did we have an emmy award
winner like she wants to help you love
and then there's another girl who's um
who's trying to slide into your dms
ugline
that's cool how are you
well to give you guys a little bit more
like inside info uh the reason i can't
apply for a normal work visa is because
i'm a plebian i have no education i'm 21
years old
uh so apparently the government doesn't
like that yeah you're not elite enough
[ __ ] that you're saying
we tried applying to to bring love over
we got a really good lawyer
to bring him over on a work visa but
apparently i didn't know that you need
like a
degree
which was so [ __ ] stupid
here is you're receiving a
listen academy or nobel prize
oh wow i forgot about that yeah you
might be able to parlay this yeah
this is proof yeah that's the king of
sweden right there bro right give him
some [ __ ] respect yeah absolutely he
has articles i didn't recognize him at
first because he's not wearing a hat
all right yeah now there's articles as
well
about this stuff his twitch stream that
when he was true that's true you have
you have the fart thing parted in front
of police
powerful that actually that is i don't
know if that is something that is
something it would look good on a feed
no it is something it proves it wasn't
actually an arrest
or whatever also you do have does ryan
cavanaugh look like harvey weinstein you
have a number
you had it's not number one anymore
sadly well we're working on it
um i mean yeah i think like there's also
this thing called a million dollar green
card i'm just putting that out there
maybe we could crowdfund a million
dollars i don't know what wait what
what does that mean i'm kidding
no i'm kidding uh there is uh people has
been telling me about it there's like
million dollar green card so basically
if you have a million dollars
you can can't be true no it's true
if you buy like a company
uh or you invest a million dollars into
a company you're pretty much getting
card for immigrant investors sure enough
this is what we're just going to be rich
your immigration allows for certain
non-citizens who are employment-based
immigrants to become lawful permanent
residents get slash get a green card
uh includes non-citizens who invested or
are actively in the process of investing
one million fifty thousand dollars is
that extra fifty thousand that really
gets you one million fifteen thousand
in a new commercial enterprise that will
benefit the us economy and create whoa
positions oh eb5 i've heard of this
before so love i'll i'll do i'll do a
payroll one million uh
see even if i did that i'd have to send
you like over two million for you to
actually have enough right
oh yeah isn't that [ __ ] up
i don't actually don't know how that
works maybe though in sweden there's
zero gift tax by the way it's pretty
cool just can i gift a million dollars
though because there's a limit here on
which you can get i don't know i don't
know i have to run that by my account
what do you guys think i won't do i'll
just gift you every month give it to him
in crypto if they evade the banks
tax-free baby right yeah yeah just [ __ ]
give them i gotta make a crypto casino
launder them a couple of nfts give them
some board apes
that crypto [ __ ]
well then there's a lot of different
visas i don't know
all right well we just we need to we
need to get love a million bucks there's
that that's on the tab at least there's
the option on the table
yeah we need to explore all options
yeah right
saudi prince you you in on this where
are you at you got a million
a million i i got i got like
four
i got some money saved up so you don't
need the whole meal
but like ninety-nine percent of it
pretty much so i got some money saved up
yeah that's something everything [ __ ]
ass up and work well this this girl
who's trying to slide in your damn she
donated 200 so she's obviously somewhat
stacked she's afraid to juice stop i
think yeah um
with that option too
juiced up
all right so we'll work we'll work on
that in the meantime
this next story is uh pretty interesting
keemstar's bestie fussy tube tastes like
beef jerky
um it tastes like beef jerky there was a
big fight over the weekend where with
ksi
and a bunch of other people deji
ksi's little brother who i like i think
he's a very sweet guy i've talked to him
but he's lost like three fights in a row
brutally
actually what's interesting is he fought
jake paul first and he made his ass
bleed
yeah from what i've seen he has good
power which is he was uh there's always
his stamina
he looks so good well anyway he looked
good yesterday didn't he look like he
looked like a monster yeah he fought a
fusi
and he [ __ ] annihilated fouseytube
uh taste i bet his [ __ ] face tastes
like beef jerky at the moment or looks
like beef jerky anyway
people said fussy spent uh more
[ __ ] you think you went white
enough on this
i felt ugly there's something we said
for realistic shades
i felt worthless
this is show muscle this is real
training i guess right what do you think
about that ab
i i look more like deji than i did like
fousey so yeah i agree
people said uh yeah
that foosie spent more time
making progress videos than training
fousey fought once before and famously
his face was pulverized he had to get
like facial reconstruction surgery yeah
two surgeries two nose jobs
and he put out a post saying
my doctor told me i can't fight because
if my nose gets broken again
it can be really bad right i felt ugly
but i'm sure his best friend and
business partner keemstar
was
super
worried about his health and be like
buddy do the right thing you don't need
to step into the ring
i felt gay
i was waiting for that one to drop
[Laughter]
that is such a good [ __ ] drop
yes
so
it was actually a good fight deji looked
super good i'm real happy for him no
well
but another good fight i mean it was
good in that
there were worse fights
i mean fousey didn't really land
anything but there was worse fights i
mean i remember we watched fousey's
original fight
several times he's better than that i
didn't really think he had improved no
he would die in that fight he literally
wouldn't the guy was just punching him
he would didn't his hands were like this
with deji i think they were up i mean
they were up for they were just like it
was just like wide open i didn't get to
watch the whole thing because i was busy
all weekend but the clips i saw a lot of
the fighters including fousey and i
don't want to act like here's a b
but i'm just saying one of the like
common amateur mistakes is when
someone's going to hit you your natural
reaction is to reach out and move the
hand okay and that is like the biggest
my coach would get so mad because when
you do that you're open on all sides and
even in that picture fousey's doing that
you see his hand he's pushing away
uh yeah or above this one [ __ ]
wait above this photo hey hold on chat
why are you guys talking about pride
minute i didn't say it's pride minute
because because the foosies oh [ __ ] yeah
who's the announcement i'll tell you
guys when it's private that's not
private back in the closet
for real freaks thank you gifted subs uh
penguin uh
i can't read the full name
50 gifted subs thank you wow what a
legend i think that is the oiler
referring to
uh putting all the oilers in chat up for
my
like they're they're going to gather and
help me for my visa
oil spoilers
yes the oil barons oh the oil
we have a couple oilers yeah uh penguin
and bella chime in that's maybe if
penguin and bella chime in uh thank you
for the gifted 50 gifted subs oh man you
guys are so nice
want to show my gra thank you xavier i
want to show my gratitude for the entire
podcast team my girlfriend isn't doing
well my mom is injured been hard without
my entire support system but you guys
have kept my head on
and i really appreciate it thank you
brother
xavier you love me
yeah xavier
so anyway
he gets punched in the [ __ ] face real
hard many times man
knocked down
and um
i'll be uh
i'll be honest
i i thought i thought for sure fousey
was gonna win because he was just so
shredded and he looked so fit but
the man forgot to train how to box yeah
exactly i listen
i didn't lift any weights from my fight
i mean i wish i i did a little bit but i
don't know how it is at every other gym
but um when i asked where the weights
were my coach told me your body is the
weight yeah and when i went in the other
day i went to go visit wally i told him
i pulled my arm he said why you lift why
were you lifting weights what's wrong
with push-ups like i don't know if
everyone's like that but when i saw him
that ripped i'm like he probably spent
way too much time uh just lifting
weights rather than learning how to box
i think you're absolutely right you know
look at this though it's awesome
um
here he is afterwards jesus christ
his eye is completely shut his nose is
like
three times bigger than its normal size
and then this was a really great
observation we found out where they got
their boxing logo from
it's pretty good
right on huh
you know i feel bad for fousey it's just
a shame that like somehow keemstar has
got his tendrils around him and he's
like
like lucy you're free of the keemstar
curse and now look what's happening to
your life again i feel bad for him too
i've only seen face banks ever like
defend him before when he was having an
episode saying he's having a manic
episode take it easy on him and keem's
like
no no that's not what this is yeah
yes dude fousey said keemstar made him
want to un-alive himself yeah i think
with keemstar people really get like
this stock home or i don't have a
stockholm sooner but they're so
desperate for him to leave them alone
that they'll
they'll take anything like being his
friend
as like uh you know to stop his
harassment he really is that delicious
chad's saying fousey's eyebrows look
great though those eyebrows are true
nice arch
but are the but those are painted on
right no they're not painted they're
just done
they might be tinted i feel like those
are darkened dude he uh i feel like the
sweat would have wiped i come from a
town where all the dudes do their
eyebrows we uh didn't he he tattooed his
head though right yeah he is a fake
hairline those are clean brows like he
definitely got them waxed those are yeah
yeah this is strong eyebrows then
because yeah that's a lot of canvas for
real a lot of real estate happening okay
player
it looks real good i mean like this part
where it's swollen it really it really
didn't yeah it didn't affect the earth
at all i felt ugly if anything like it
made the brow even better yes look at
the way it raised that arch
it's like he's always yeah yeah yeah if
anything good came out of it you look
stunning stunning stunning
love check your dms i'm coming in hot
to battle a lean
for your hand in green card marriage
baby this is from harley 50 bucks i'm
telling you love
listen you're a dreamboat you're a
little cutie pie you're a dreamboat man
thank you don thank you guys thank you
we love you let's get you out here 90
day fiance
we can have our own 90 day fiance just
record everything watch them fight
hey watch the relationship fall apart
between your legs
oh great content huh
thank you chloe
it would be it would be of course
now this was fousey after his last fight
in 2020
we should all pick actually he looks
bad
i think
i think he's really really injured
where's the post he uh here's the
he shared a post yeah here
he posted his thoughts on the fight
look at him man
dude
bro
jerky
here he says i was going to keep this
private but with all my current emotions
i'mma just own it the first time i boxed
my nose broke so bad it required two
surgeries to fix
i had told myself i would never get in
the ring again because of it and then i
made keemstar
just kidding that's not in there
when this opportunity arose i called the
dock and asked him if it would be okay
he said absolutely not if you were to
get hit again the break will be even
worse and cause problems
because of how bad i wanted another
chance for myself i said so be it
well ask and you shall receive just left
the doc's office sure enough and it's
broken and will require surgery this
week
looking in the mirror brings up so many
mixed emotions i have two options one
complain cry mope feel sorry for myself
sent regret blame others
you know blame others as keemstar
who else
right who else
or to thank god smile and count my
blessings
it's time to start counting them
blessings
foosie bro
the one time deji goes beast mode by the
way
yeah
everyone was saying that one of them has
to win so
one of them got a dub at least his chin
was fine though from the beard stopped
most the impact
this poor man dude holy smokes
look how big his nose is
it's keemstar's fault look at this [ __ ]
anyway foose i hope you're okay and that
uh
stupid [ __ ] you evaluate your
friendships quote unquote friendships in
your life and uh how they're influencing
you
in it
i wish you would have vlogged
him going to the doctor
and being like i did it
he's like i can tell dude you're faking
like beef jerky on that note without
going too deep into it whenever you're
talking about keem and that aiden ross
stream he told aiden you should box
you'd be great at it and the other guy's
like no don't box and keem's like yeah
i'm just lying i just like to i just
like to start [ __ ] wow you pulled up
some weird deep [ __ ]
yeah i'm sure he did he's like fussy
you're you're a killer you're gonna kill
him that first part you just didn't
practice enough yeah you'll be good
but my doctor said if i get punched in
the nose again i could die your doctor's
a quack bro listen to me
[ __ ] doctors
can't wait to report your death
yeah
great guy
uh moving on
i wonder if yeah taking a few sips of
beer would cure his nose
moving on this story got me s giggling
bro
um
chat is saying don't let hassan near his
eye hole that's true man
that eye hole is looking nice
katie wow
a story came out about jennifer lopez j
lo
she fired dancers based on their
astrological sign how [ __ ] epic is
that this is a new form of
discrimination
astrological discrimination
we must protect our it's an ancient form
of discrimination actually
was anyone really ever discriminated on
the basis of birth sign or zodiac yeah
right and as they should
like it just seems like the craziest
[ __ ] thing
to actually
oh my god apparently
according to actress and dancer heather
morris who is known for her work on glee
told a story about one of jayla's
auditions where she asked if anyone in
the room was a virgo
i then asked them to leave all virgos
get out yeah i mean virgos of course
isn't that [ __ ] awesome
it's so funny
what's the what's wrong with virgos are
they dicks what's not wrong with it are
they the worst they're the worst and
they're bad dancers
they're bad dancers
you need to leave
you were born under a bad star the funny
thing is like
i'm like right on the cusp too it
doesn't matter
it was ugly when you were born
here i typed bad things about virgos
15 bad traits about virgos
they are perfectionists to a fault
yep
they hold themselves to impossibly high
standards
they may be overly critical
it sounds just like zach they may come
across as tightly wound oh yeah
they can be selective
they can be discontent in life yep they
can be really bad at dancing
for reals they
they don't advertise they defecate in
all kinds of different places their
brains are jokerfied
[Music]
um
the list goes on
they hate ccr
they're overly considerate
they're they're just such good people
it's so small
they are excessively independent they
sometimes feel good and then sometimes
feel bad
virgos sometimes are happy and sometimes
sad yeah for real
that is so true uh a virgo can be
annoyingly critical fussy pedantic
argumentative complaining anal retentive
and indecisive sounds like exactly [ __ ]
out virgos
virgos i don't think that stuff actually
describes you at all zach yeah i'm qui
i'm throwing this whole asteroid are you
an astrology thing in the question what
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
what are you doing marc anthony her
ex-husband is a virgo i don't know if
that has anything to do who's virgo
her ex-husband mark anthony
mark martin anthony jayla's ex-husband
oh he's a oh so she's just
discriminating
they were together for a whole decade
and maybe she realized you know they're
just she didn't know she didn't know his
birthday
lena do you know if they had a really
bad breakup divorce
i don't think so they share two kids and
even now they they seem to get along
well what's his name mark anthony famous
singer isn't that like a name of like a
[ __ ] great a roman warrior
killer
no you're right he's
leader of the armies of the north this
guy father to a murder child yeah that's
him this [ __ ] is a virgo huh
he just makes sense he should have known
better virgo this man looks like steve
buscemi i'm just gonna say
he's like the uh
okay
shout out mark anthony not bad for a
[ __ ] virgo
we're brothers in arms my friend
they say they may be overly skeptical
they tend to be obsessive about
cleanliness
they can be stingy
cheap ass
there it is
zach you're on notice
el zach if there's any virgos watching
please turn off please leave
we gotta go
so i guess i'll uh i'll see you guys
maybe you're gonna hold the fort down
right we need everybody show me where
the [ __ ] one's at okay cool see you guys
okay so wait i'm a cancer that's my sign
so i'm gonna do now i'll do it by myself
uh about myself bad traits
about cancers
they're like cancers really can [ __ ]
your body up because he can't even be
fatal not that one
we'll get cancer in the butthole
okay tell me if you guys think this um
if this describes me moody
cancers are emotional sometimes too
emotional
paranoid
definitely
can't just want to know everything
that's going on so if they don't they
get extremely paranoid
flighty
what does that mean flighty
being a water sign cancer is sometimes
seen as flighty like short attention
span
oh that's true you like to take an
airplane somewhere self-worth
can't just don't take too kindly to
criticism vindictive
could be you could be described as
vindictive they nailed me on that
[ __ ]
got me good
oh [ __ ] is there a new jimmy lee drop
what the [ __ ] did he even respond to you
zack
yeah he um
but not about that
dude mason is out of control
how do i give my avatar histrionic
personality disorder
audio audio audio jimmy lee in the
metaverse thanks to h3h3
i don't think jimmy's even aware of that
i'm just gonna say this is starting to
feel like a britney situation to me is
do we need a free jimmy lee is this
mason just he's in a gym conservatorship
[ __ ]
yo what this guy's kind of a genius how
do i give my avatar his geonic
personality disorder that's what i'm
saying we just got to get mason on the
show forget jimmy
are you working on that zach mason
absolutely he hasn't responded to the
idea though so
hmm i feel like it might be easier just
to call him after the show
are we positive mason is real
yes who else is making that oh i was
living under the guise that mason was
possibly like jimmy's artistic self
you know oh like steve rossi dude
those are way through
yeah i think those are way too good
there's too much photoshop skill well
isn't jimmy just reposting every dm he
gets so like people are sending it could
be that there's a random poster that's
just sending everything i think
i think there's only one other person it
could be
uh and that's cameron this is no
camera style no no no exactly he's not
his style he's underselling it uh uh cam
i love you but he also said in the text
he's all tell cam thanks okay appreciate
it he's throwing he's just throwing me
under the bus like he throws you guys
under the bus and it's like thanking you
cameron yeah
look at that yeah don't believe baby for
this one oh you made it no look at that
post and tell me that's my style wait is
it it's not no but i don't know you want
to do it in your style i think you could
switch it up if it was too good we would
know it's you yeah wait jimmy just said
thank you to cam right now yeah he's
handy
did you like that no i did not hand to
god he said
the first text i sent him he responded
sure
um zach
tell cam thanks appreciate you guys
helping well ask him what he's thanking
me for specifically maybe it just might
be because i was wearing the t-shirt
earlier oh okay yeah okay i was his
model that's why
but you are sweating though i'm
suspicious no i just don't want to
i i i know you i wouldn't go behind your
back and work on i know i know that's
not your style man yeah thank you cam
lee you got a special touch and it's not
there
well that's a special touch too i don't
want to throw whoever that was under the
bus but it ain't me oh it's a special
toucher right and for the record i don't
actually think it's cameron i'm just
saying if it was anyone else
i'd guess cam
so it was very nice you guys know who
sydney sweeney is
she's a big star from
euphoria super popular show on hbo which
i'm a fan of i watched it all i like it
she was like
the heartthrob i guess i don't know
one of them one of them yeah i'll show
you a picture but a really kind of
interesting story developed i'm curious
to get your guys's take you probably
recognize her she's super like famous
now
here she is
so
this is pretty interesting
so she's facing backlash
over photos
what's sweeney land you guys you guys
know what that is
so anyway never been there
i have some intel that you got somebody
got so you guys know what sweeney land
is who the [ __ ] does message not
tell me what the [ __ ] you dan
no it wasn't dan
what are you laughing what is this
yeah what the [ __ ] i don't know what it
is ian
i've noticed that dan you seem to go
because there's no message in main chat
yeah who did you out last you just outed
oh tim dillon and a.b
so now you've got that message
you guys don't know who messaged me
i just want to know what's sweeney look
at that man's face i asked dan dan
whoever messaged you should explain it
dan came in this morning he's like y'all
trying to his do i need to google him
all right
you're not you're not going to find
anything on that
shows up zero results
you're not in
i actually got in trouble for making a
sweeney land joke on the show before
all right it's the thing i thought this
was okay i'll explain the sweeney
landlord okay
buckle up you're gonna need seat belts
when we go to sweeney lane okay all
right
what happened was one day
some of the gentlemen in the office
were talking about euphoria and the show
and
sweeney may have came up her great
acting skills
and then someone else's girlfriend
walked up and we were like oh let's
change change the topic real quick and
that girl's like i'm not stupid y'all
were talking like no we're talking about
going to disneyland next week she's like
no y'all were talking about sweeneyland
and then it just became a meme around
the office
sweeneyland so whose girlfriend walked
in on you guys
i oh i see i see i see i see
i see i see you guys were talking about
her
you guys were talking about her big jugs
is that what was going on i'm all about
uh sydney's brother trent so i'm going
to trent town trent town
trent town i got a one-way ticket to
trent town
trent town yes wait who's trent sweeney
now i want a picture of him bro that's
the brother
yeah
let me see a picture of this of this uh
trent fella
everyone's freaking out about
you going to trent town
trent town yeah all right is he a friend
rock
he looks young is he 18 i i don't know
i'm just i just like saying trent town i
think it's fun i got the pass hopper i
could go to both bob marley saying a lot
about trent town
all right so basically
apparently you guys do know who sydney
sweeney is no idea
do you guys even watch euphoria no i've
never watched it but you guys know
everyone knows whose sweet decision
sweeney is
thank you for the gifted disturbance
20 gifted thank you for gifted
legend
okay so anyway
she threw a surprise party for her mom's
60th birthday
in idaho that was cowboy themed
photos posted by sweden's brother trent
town
showed people wearing
magga hats
parody maga hats printed with make 60
great again i love it
along with somebody wearing a blue lives
matter
sure
who i think is her dad
okay wait this okay make 60 great again
okay
and then uh
she he said yeehaw happy 60th mom
and then here's another pick that's the
one sydney posted and the guy in the
middle is wearing a blue lives matter
shirt and i think that's her dad
i think i've i've read that that's her
dad went to a [ __ ] birthday party
with the blue lives matter shirt that's
pretty gnarly
that's like
when i went to school in ohio people
rocked that [ __ ] everywhere what that's
so embarrassing i was once yeah
it's just it's great my friend had a
bernie sticker on her car and we went
grocery shopping we came back and our
car was keyed
wow
just trying to get you health care bro
yeah it's not that serious
but but like it's your wife's 60th
birthday and you can't you can't [ __ ]
put on something
that ain't a
blue lives matter
that one threw me off a little bit the
party
like
accessories were a republican theme too
well nan is wearing like the confederate
dress too for real and like the hats
were like make 60 great again
that's definitely yeah so
anyway so these pics went out and people
are like wow okay well
they felt like she's coming out of the
closet as a
as a trumpy
but then she posted
a response to people freaking out
and she said this
you guys tell me what you think
you guys this is wild
an innocent celebration for my mom's
milestone 60th birthday has turned into
an absurd political statement i can see
this happening euphoria her character
uh
which is not the intention please stop
making assumptions much love to everyone
and happy birthday mom i don't think
it's a stretch if you're wearing a blue
lives matter shirt
no
but then so she getting eviscerated in
the comments assumptions your family are
wearing maga hats and blue lives matter
shirts they're racist
time to face reality sweetie
just because you're white and famous
doesn't mean you get to have it all oh
my god sue's coming for the jugular
whoa mama i thought she probably the
best route would have been like their
beliefs don't reflect mine it's my
family what are you gonna do i agree but
she didn't say but she's like what are
you guys talking about everyone wears
these shirts where i'm from yeah my
whole family's always wearing these i
kind of felt like because the photo she
posted
very like it very clearly that's a blue
lives matter shirt and if you're about
to post something especially when you
have that big of a following i feel like
you're extra careful about
not like not wanting to i guess like
boiled down it's you don't want to hurt
anyone or offend anyone
more than i feel like that's somewhat of
a statement even if she says it wasn't
like she definitely probably thought
about it at least possible that she
i mean this is if if this is the case
that she doesn't know what a blue lives
matter shirt is then she's okay sure
dumb
right yeah i don't know not everybody
follows
political
talk that much you know i mean like blue
lives matter such like a reoccurring
image
but anyway here's more dude she's
getting eviscerated assumptions don't
gaslight your fans
uh many are likely young progressive
people based on the content of the show
that gave you fame that's true your
family is obviously far right based on
the blue lives matter shirt and maga
baby this is her brother
her other brother apparently posted
what the hell look at those cheeks
forget about the hat
my goodness
uh this is her brother with the
his daughter in a
maga hat outside the white house
but the maggot had to me it's like
whatever you know he was president fine
the blue lives matter shirt that's like
[ __ ]
gnarly
i kind of agree with dan that she may
not know what it is i mean
when i was younger i thought it was just
for cops in general just like
showing support to cops i think it's
possible she didn't know where it was i
don't think she would have posted it
yeah but when she posted her like you
guys this is wild i'm sure by that point
she had been informed of what it is and
she still didn't say it right it's a
good point
so i don't know i was like i don't know
if people are overreacting but like your
dad wearing a blue lives matter shirt is
pretty [ __ ] up
i just don't know
it's pretty
wild like yeah it sucks so much that in
this
day and age you're always making a
statement but like
you are that's like wearing a
confederate
yeah it's
you know i mean there are there's
blatant imagery that
signals to me whether or not i want to
be friends yes
also that's a good point euphoria is a
a lot about like trans people and uh
liberal identities yeah like sex scenes
and stuff too
seeing
sydney sweeney get jumped is beautiful
if you're white and unwilling to
completely shame your parents for their
conservative views you're just as
complicit and need to be escorted out
that's easier said than done i mean i'm
lucky because my parents are very
[ __ ] lib
so i don't know what kind of situation
that be in but just don't you know
let's do a poll are people overreacting
or
or
what i think what are the options it's
dumb to assume that no one's going to
talk about it
what are the options if we do a pull
here
people are overreacting or
people are
properly reacting yeah
or under reacting
under reacting what more can they do
burn their burn her house down the
funniest thing from
sydney sweeney's [ __ ] is all the white
people
we all have racist families like hello
that's funny
uh this is sydney sweeney's grandma i
fear
was that the uh insurrectionist grandma
yeah
that's so funny
you knew them supple white titties ain't
coming from no liberal gene pool
what the [ __ ] kid
oh my god disgusting that's that is
disgusting
be respectful toxic that sounds like
something that would be taking place at
the sweeney land circle
no no no honestly in all seriousness no
one was talking about her looks i swear
to god
we really weren't her lips her looks
you were talking about what a great
actor we're really just talking about
the show but we made it look suspicious
the way we were all like yeah
you guys were just like yo she's such a
good actor she's amazing yeah her acting
skills are insane yeah i'm like dude
she's such a good actress those big ass
titties don't even distract me
[Laughter]
shame on you guys oh thank god olivia
left you saved me with that one
you knew them
sydney sweeney if she didn't act on
euphoria fox news female starter
pack usually wears red white and blue
exclusively looks only this and nothing
else jesus
this is good this [ __ ] always blows my
mind though
that this is the actual lineup on fox
news man
you could have cloned these ladies and
uh sydney sweeney's brother looks like
he watches all of her scenes oh
[Music]
holy [ __ ] oh no
holy [ __ ]
sydney sweeney hiding in nancy pelosi's
bathtub on january 6th oh my goodness
that's the scene from the show obviously
i for one am shocked that sydney sweeney
a blonde with huge titties that works
for on classic cars for fun has
republican parents
uh sydney sweeney's dad watching her get
back shots from a black man in euphoria
dude
chill
wait she was getting back shots it was
in like the
i think it's one of the first episodes
right
he was
there was shot to that i mean i didn't
actually what no i'm not i don't think
there's actual shots that's just implied
jesus this is vulgar cindy sweeney when
you ask where her and her family were on
january 6th
cindy sweeney's dad after seeing her
have sex with the black man in season
one dude this [ __ ] bro this [ __ ] is
insane
this is too much
this is
this is way too much you guys gotta
chill dude
what's even the context okay okay so
that's hulk hogan
yeah and in in wwf
he was something called nwa it was new
world
organization or it was yeah it didn't
stand for what you think it did oh he
didn't know nwa was no it just it's i'm
not defending it i'm just kidding i'm
saying
that's incredible
anything else besides nwa but it's
incredible that somebody actually
fished this image out
to fit i mean well i think it was nw
it's a meme well hulk already had his
whole scandal because he there was that
video of him yelling the n-word about
his daughter's
boyfriend or whatever i'm sorry you're
right it's nwa it's new world order i
believe or new world order no national
wrestling alliance
unless there's so it was ending okay
okay
sidney sweeney compiling the guest list
for her mom's birthday party
jesus
absolutely let's go to the poll and see
yeah she got dragged so hard man
okay interesting so
overreacting has a slight lead here
reacting correctly
46 that's interesting and five percent
thinks that someone needs to go burn her
[ __ ] house down five percent
everything
i think boycotting her or her show for
her family's beliefs aren't i'm not
boycotting like what's that gonna do but
i think discourse about it is it's
warranted
yeah
i mean listen the blue lives matter
shirt is pretty charged guys
it's it's like interesting i want to
know why
love i've been in your situation now i
have a green card
happy to tell you my processes as you
navigate with me the visa stuff and
maybe this info helps you
oh thank you yeah i mean i'll take any
kind of information from anyone
oh very interested thank you thank you
thank you
what are you what are you giggling about
zach yo everybody's super mad that
zach said nwa not nwo so i was just
saying what the nwa wrestling thing
stands for what are like you don't know
[ __ ] about wwe
[ __ ] up
okay
jesus he said nwa i was just explaining
what that was chill apparently nwo was
hogan's thing or whatever forgive me
sorry hey by the way wrestling fans it's
not real sorry
whoa
come on now dan w dan
no
it was straight out of hogan was in nwo
don't mess with the wrestling fans
i'm a wrestling fan for life dude cool
i'm d generation x man it's all me
so anyway
i wa to answer your question ethan i was
laughing because
you're like i'm still gonna watch it
yeah
i'm just making a point that
i'm not gonna boycott her because of it
no it was just funny how you said it i'm
sorry
i can't compete with that i i can never
be the golden boy you say one joke he's
laughing for five because it's the
timing of it it's the timing of it i
mean i don't get laughter like that from
zach all the time
you need to laugh harder baby i mean i
guess so i'll keep going to acknowledge
it
yeah
that's it just laugh more harder
maybe i'll love you as much as that oh
uh overreacting 49 so there you have it
okay interesting
somewhat polarizing
uh issue there the memes are really just
right themselves though
how long we've been going dan
uh two and a half hours
so we got the record heat wave in china
and pakistan and flooding in pakistan
this [ __ ] is nuts dude our planet is so
[ __ ]
meanwhile in china
uh they're having like unprecedented
heatwave the whole country is just
consumed
with
an unbelievable heat wave
factories are shutting down um because
power stations are overloaded yeah it's
just the whole country is like shut down
right now coming with that heat here it
is here's a size of it
is it me or do you not really hear about
the stuff in
that much
yeah like nothing i don't necessarily
agree because it seems like this stuff
is pretty catastrophic what's going on i
feel like i'm seeing a lot of people on
social media saying why is nobody
talking about this
um
but i mean it it's all over
the mainstream news and stuff
okay i don't know it's like it's just a
weird phenomenon
this is far from the only story but you
often times see this where it's like
nobody's talking about this thing and
it's like
i mean
if you just pakistan floods
but why is it man there's articles on
twitter all
like 39 minutes ago new york times it's
not depending on twitter dan i didn't
right and that's the thing is it's just
like if the algorithm isn't putting it
directly in front of your face all the
time then it people don't care nobody
cares yeah nobody's talking about it a
lot of people on chat saying the first
time they heard about it yeah i think i
think
so there is like a once in a [ __ ]
thousand year heat wave it's a
a large ridge of high pressure look at i
mean i don't know what this map means
but i saw
a good
tick talk about it is that in here the
one i said yeah
okay
you want to highlight it for me
which which tick tock in particular you
sent a view and there's one about the
chinese heat wave
uh
the chinese heat wave
oh you talking about the one with the
where they show the rockets or whatever
yeah i i just i just pulled the actual
article that was from because i'll just
read this um so there's a oh there's
massive drought well there was a video
that showed like all the lake beds
drying up and [ __ ]
okay
um this article is old
that is the article that that tick tock
was just reading that article
yeah i just i guess i just wanted the
videos okay yeah this what the [ __ ] yeah
this is old
all right i'm gonna read this hopefully
we can find the videos
china is experiencing a drought and the
worst heat wave ever
record-setting drought
on an 11-week heat wave
are causing broad disruptions in china
a region that depends on dams for more
than three quarters of its electricity
yeah it's insane you see like lake beds
rivers [ __ ] they're just bone dry
uh more than 900 million people across
17 chinese provinces
are subjected to record-breaking
conditions
with temperatures topping 40
celsius
non-stop
factories owned by foxconn toyota and
volkswagen have curtailed production or
closed lack due to lack of power
owners of electric cars are waiting
overnight at charging stations
and in shangdu the capital of this uh
sichuan province
several neighborhoods went without
electricity for more than 10 hours per
day
here we go thank you dan
this is everyone needs to know what is
happening in china right now the last 70
days straight china have been
experiencing the most extreme heat event
in world history for some reason no one
is talking about it lakes and rivers
have dried up crops have been killed
factories have been closed and this heat
wave is still raging on just for
perspective this is the lake bed of
china's largest fresh water source and
this is the state of the third largest
river in the world on top of that 66 of
their other rivers have dried up
completely in the daytime you're seeing
temperatures of 45 degrees celsius
you're not even getting a break as it's
hovering around a statement
113 bro that there was nothing 113
for 13 would they say 13 weeks straight
11 11 weeks in the world's
climatic history which is even minimally
comparable to what is happening in china
right now he says that it combines the
most extreme intensity with the most
extreme length with an incredibly huge
area all at the same time and the
effects of something this extreme is
gonna affect us all i mean we saw the
prices of food fuel and energy soar due
to the situation
yeah so it's it's like catastrophic
uh and then meanwhile you look at china
dry
getting absolutely brutalized by this
heat wave and drought
and then meanwhile in pakistan
they're being they're getting so much
rain that
like
their
huge amounts of the country are just
being brutally insanely flooded
is that this is what global
climate change does it just intensifies
weather
patterns
you know where it's dry gets drier
and where it's wet it gets wetter and
it's just
it's crazy man i watched a lot of these
reminding me of like and sharing your
mind
some of the footage reminded me of like
the tsunamis in japan
um here
this is the one i was talking about
look at
that what the [ __ ]
800 almost 800 percent higher rain than
usual in some areas
eight times the normal amount of rain
this is like i just think it's
incredible that people are still acting
like this isn't a problem
it's just incredible
such [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] dude
[Music]
we got jordan peterson out here talking
about what is climate anyway
you know
what does it mean climate noted noted
climate scientist jordan peterson the
environment a lot to say what is the
environment that's everything
meanwhile pakistan they're like [ __ ]
dying
a fact getting flooded in china they're
like don't have water duty
i mean here in l.a we're [ __ ] too man
i don't even remember the last time it
rained here
i mean it rained
it rained a couple days earlier this
year but not nearly enough
it wasn't like a wide stretch i don't
know man
it's it's bad it's bad
the climate change is bad bad bad bad
bad bad bad this is and this kind of
stuff is just going to happen more and
more and more and more every year
just
just bad
it's thank you quartering at least i
agree
but the amount of [ __ ] politicians in
america that prioritize
like fossil fuels or investments in
their own money like joe manchin who's
going to hell um
it's it's
well since we don't have a strike i'll
just say it they need i'm just kidding
yeah
dude
i looked at my music
am i fast enough to grab it
i feel everyone in the office just get
tense real quick
dude gotcha i was like that you guys
good boy
no i just i just hope david's okay
though
yeah
true
it's so scary man yeah nothing makes me
feel like more doomed
this is this is horrifying it doesn't
need to be happening to me to know that
this is [ __ ] up it is happening in la
though i don't know what we're gonna do
because
meanwhile in l.a i don't know if you
guys saw the story maybe you guys can
pull it up the kardashians there's a
water embargo yeah here in la you can
only use a certain amount of water
because they were in a big old drought
and the kardashians used like 300 000
gallons over
their limit there's a bunch of people in
their neighborhood
they got busted for using like hundreds
of thousands of gallons of water that's
just alone too
and what's crazy about that is like
there's
the money whatever fees nothing like
they literally
can waste a finite resource life-saving
resource
and there's no [ __ ] accountability at
all it's incredible isn't it
kim kardashian several other celebrities
are facing backlash after report
revealed how much they're exceeded their
home water limits
check this out
uh
can we get to the point here buzzfeed
among the list of celebrities in
question were sisters kim and courtney
who have reportedly exceeded their limit
by a combination of over three hundred
thousand gallons how much water is that
so to put into context they've surpassed
150 percent of their
monthly water budgets at least four
times since the agency declared a
drought emergency it's only fifty
percent over 150 over
why do that seems like they can use too
much water
i just looked up the original la times
article where this is all being sourced
from
and um you know the kardashians are huge
so they're getting all the attention
but i see that the worst uh violator was
a former nba star dwayne wade
that in may
his property exceeded its water budget
if i get this
489 thousand gallons
half a million gallons of water water is
that i'm just curious like how much is
half a million
gallons
right like what what like
body of water that's a half a million
gallon pool or something i don't know
sylvester stallone used 230
hundred
230 000 excess gallons of water more
than 533 percent their allocated budget
this is the most like [ __ ] the rich
people i've
story i've heard in a long time we're
talking about a finite resource they're
literally dumping
here this is a 500 000
gallon
wave pool
so like a whole wave pool
yeah i just looked it up an average
swimming pool is around 20 000
gallons of water are you [ __ ] kidding
oh
500
000 divided by 20 000.
it's 25 swimming pools worth of water
god
what was he even doing with that water
this guy they just have awesome make
broom in the pool all day just
continuously spilling it going in
circles
i mean huge lawns
okay um yeah which yeah i mean at this
point
like
why grass shouldn't be allowed here in
southern california yeah it's time like
we should just
say no more no more grass lawns no more
grasslands smoke the grass though it's
not that important we should get rid of
all the [ __ ]
golf courses sorry at all the golfers
golf lovers out there yeah golf is so
bad yeah i mean are you [ __ ] kidding
me you're growing grass in the desert
during a drought yeah it just you can't
you can't do it here you can't it's just
not realistic 100 000 square foot water
park might use
125 000 gallons of water per day
so they're running uh
a whole water park for five days
[ __ ]
hurricane harbor i mean these people are
[ __ ] man it was dwyane wade that was
using the 500.
yeah oh yeah dwayne wade was the highest
to be fair he was on the miami heat
so he needs lots of water eh
oh
you look like my favorite greek
restaurant
i saw that in a comment that's not
original
good one man
good catch me anyway here's what's
happening in pakistan
move to pakistan they got water you can
run your [ __ ] sprinklers all day and
night
i don't think anyone i think everyone
got out safely so i watch this
yeah that's true hey daddy i'm telling
you bro this is crazy but they get out
that's i think a lot of people have uh
perished as not surprisingly yeah the
official report said over a thousand
yeah i was about to say
no this guy gets out bro okay i watch
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] lives
watch it it's incredible
close the trunk
i'm telling you this guy lives man
so he said no grass in l.a sounds like
hell on earth why why do you need grass
so bad
well hell on earth is when you can't
when you run out of drinking water right
yeah let's
make a sacrifice on the grass front
maybe they were being sarcastic like
yeah maybe
look at this this man survived
this is straight out of a movie
so you want to come to my car
pretty incredible
uh but but this [ __ ] is so scary
yeah
yeah apparently uh in around 2010
pakistan had really severe flooding like
this as well
but
they're saying that they think that this
is probably already worse and it's not
over yet wow
i saw um because these monsoons kind of
happen in cycles and there's already
been far more monsoon downpours than in
previous years does it happen every 10
years though or is that too frequent
look at this [ __ ] dude
well i mean happens every year they get
they get monsoons but like monster
monsoon but
well i'm saying in 2010 they had another
really severe season but they think this
is already worse and it's not over yet
uh look how much water is i mean this is
insane
look at these people don't give a [ __ ]
bro they're on like a freeway overpass
this guy's got like a
i guess they're trying to save their
whole livelihood so right i think they
they probably do good
yeah they probably do several [ __ ]
yeah they do they they care
scary scary stuff
yeah i was mentioning this maybe last up
but
people are predicting that this could
happen in l.a a mega flood like this
yeah yeah
i saw that
it's not just la isn't it like all of
like the western uh oh
i think it's the whole west coast wow
could potentially have like a mega
mega storm like this sometime
time to go to texas baby
well they get it there too i don't think
you're texas was remember dallas that
yeah
years ago remember thank god jake paul
went and saved people with his jet ski
right he did i forgot about that what
that's so crazy he was jet skiing around
the neighborhood like wow this is so
[ __ ] up
[ __ ] i totally forgot about water stop
it
[Laughter]
we don't care
yeah it's scary it's very scary very sad
it's just crazy to see these two polar
opposite events
catastrophes happening at the same time
it's [ __ ] up man pakistan and china
aren't that far from each other right
it's
crazy so scary
what what have we done
we do about it we have really [ __ ] up
man
ow
nothing
nothing okay yeah we're good
hey hey howie what do we do about all
this
nothing
fair okay well good because
ow that's what's happening a thousand
one hundred people have died since the
monsoon began
confirmed
100 amps they've been displaced
officials estimate that more than 33
million pakistanis
one in seven people have been affected
by the historic flooding
and pakistan is not a super rich country
when these people lose their home and
their houses and their neighborhood
they're that's like it's gonna be very
expensive that is devastating man
devastating
this year's record monsoon is comparable
to the devastating floods and noah's ark
it says
no it didn't say that it said a 2010.
the deadliest in pakistan's history
so wow ten years later we're already
topping that yep
almost half a century of cotton crops
have been washed away vegetable fruit
and rice fields have sustained
significant damage as well
how about that man
nothing
shout out to any of our fans in pakistan
i saw someone say why isn't h3 talked
about ukraine we talked about it quite a
bit in the beginning
i'm following it i don't know what you
want me to say i mean it's just
you know still going
on putin i want it to end i want the
[ __ ] russians to get the [ __ ] out of
there but
they launched like a huge counter
offensive apparently i heard today or
yesterday last night
the
yeah it seems to have
stagnated quite a bit in recent months
just
constant fighting happening in the east
and everything
i'm checking right now to see if how
many uh audience members in pakistan we
have i don't suspect that it will be
pakistan that not many [ __ ] i've
consistently been surprised
by
that would surprise me i mean just i'm
not going to say it's going to be a lot
but let's see
we are taking a a survey of our
pakistani
members
um top 50 results
well it's not on the top 50.
yeah i could be surprised if a lot of
people from pakistan watch this show
there is a way
dan is still crunching numbers in the
meantime
our hearts and thoughts go out
to the good people of china and pakistan
uh thoughts and prayers everybody
and uh
let's bring some call in their honor huh
shout out to the coworkers
burn
burn
check this out
this one is so nuts dude
look how the water just comes out of
nowhere too
all right
tick tock leave me the [ __ ] alone bro i
swear to god this abs gonna be the end
of me
[Music]
[Applause]
in the last month
we had
11 000 people in pakistan watch the show
11 000 real ones over in pakistan shout
out to my kings and queens in pakistan
sir we love you
how about that
let's send jimmy lee out there to do a
set
anywhere
we gotta send jimmy lee up there
maybe a world tour go to ukraine well
you know how like
comedians they do tours for the troops
that's jimmy lee
we'll send them to their like uh
the camps where everyone got displaced
yeah
bob hopes hey as you say modern day bob
hope they found a weapon of masterpiece
just a little bit worse
i heard you guys are living in the
street probably used to that
hey
you're not white hey night looks like
you're you upgraded your houses nice
don't shoot
hey where's your papers oh yeah i'm in
pakistan
here it is though
these people were like
picnicking
dude look how much [ __ ] water look at
the size of the rocks in here
look at these rocks dude
[Music]
go run
they don't understand some of them don't
really get it yet
oh yeah here
scary [ __ ] dude
let's burn some coal
let's get donald back in office so we
can burn some coal
yeah
come on peggy
dumps
the weather's taking out all of our
enemies we just gotta burn coal and let
god sort them out
you're telling me if i burn coal the
chinese die of thirst
that's a w
a george w
[Music]
come on now everybody light your trash
on fire ladies and gentlemen we are all
domestic terrorists you hear what's
going down in china
there's a billion people that don't have
water let's burn some coal
hey who wants to take a
who wants to take a uh
a cruise
you know cruises bro give me some cruise
stats on pollution like one cruise
burns so much fuel on one voyage
it's astounding you gotta i need stats
who wants to go on a cruise
for every time you take a cruise you
have a big mac on a cruise a chinese
person dies of thirst
it is estimated that cruise ships
contribute 24 to the toilet solid waste
generated by maritime traffic across the
world
but i'm talking so so i just wasted
you're not actually talking about like
carbon yeah just carbon that's just [ __ ]
but that's great
number
of about 25 million cruise ship
passengers in 2017 uh right pre-pandemic
because i'm sure it's dropped off a lot
it can be estimated that the average
cruise ship passenger emits uh .8 tons
of carbon dioxide equivalent for their
cruise
is the equivalent to a return air trip
from london to tokyo
i mean people do that all the time too
but i mean air travel is really bad
um
here this is what i was looking for
one cruise ship
emissions are the same
as one million cars
[Laughter]
i'm serious
yeah it's so [ __ ] up
a cruise ship's emissions are the same
as one million cars that's gotta stop
yeah no cruise ships are an abomination
of god you have to stay land cruises
cruises stay out of the ocean literally
but look at this it's like look at look
at this abomination we've built if
you're a mermaid or a fish
stay out of the ocean you need to tap
like a whole [ __ ] new oil
well to power this thing
[ __ ] a million cars
all of them are run on the dirtiest fuel
you can imagine it's heavy fuel oil and
it's quite toxic
it's a residual of the petrol industry
and it contains a lot of dirty stuff
cruise companies know what they are
doing and they know about the problems
but they still
order new ships and don't install
emission abatement systems okay so part
of the problem is that their engines are
[ __ ] disgusting too
love that for them
we should we gotta
we gotta do a special report on this i
think you need to send us on a cruise
ethan so we can investigate this problem
firsthand
one million cars dude let's go
yeehaw every time a cruise launches a
hundred thousand chinese dive thirst
damn yes
maybe if you know
we took one to like cabo or something we
could we could get some insight dan is
not you know what i i will i'll i'll do
that sometime in the future i will i
will do that
guys we're trying to make a difference
here i'd like to report on it
i'll never go on a cruise an hawaiian
shirt with a pina colada in my hand who
the [ __ ] goes on a cruise man you should
be it's like a death trap you're stuck
on the ocean there's diseases everywhere
i need to expose them we got to answer
these questions you're asking really
valuable questions right now ethan who
is it that goes on these cruises are
disgusting and there's there's only one
way to find out
that game on youtube some gumshoe 1
million
every time
every time we tap a new oil
10 grandmas die in a flood in pakistan
america
come on now
come on now
uncle sam told me if we burn enough coal
we'll destroy china we'll win the war
zach could still be a virgin if it
weren't for cruise ships
that's true thank god every day for
cruises yes there's always a bright side
i do
jokes aside
i love cruises like you know shoot me
[ __ ] the you know the missions are awful
but it's a good time man
i've never actually been on a cruise
it's a [ __ ] amazing time
well for you you seem like a cruise guy
i'm not gonna and i mean that would be
dude i dress every day like i'm ready to
go you give me the truth like i'm ready
to go yeah you're like prepared you're
dressed for a cruise i have my go bag
[Laughter]
all the shirts that blow in the wind
right i gotta go back someone asked me
about um private planes how about our
private planes i wonder too like really
bad i hope i mean like i said
although that figure is staggering like
the equivalent of a million cars for the
cruise ship i mean that
uh per passenger comparison of it being
the equivalent of a flight from tokyo to
the uk
i mean
that's happening
all the time yeah
like
non-stop
all over the world so
i imagine the airline industry is
worse than the cruise industry let's
let's let's see what
we just need to stop talking [ __ ] or
we're going to be walking everywhere for
the rest of my life
today's episode it sounds to me like the
cruise people could improve their
stats but they're not doing it all right
let's look into the private jet people
which industry causes the most pollution
i mean let's just
let's just as far as transportation
just in general number one energy
yeah i mean that makes sense obviously
transportation
20 percent of carbon emissions
agriculture
okay so it's transportation
transportation's up there but yeah i
mean that includes trucks cars well it
says this commercial freight is 40
percent passenger travel 60 percent
cruises is uh 70
no
the stats don't even add up
um
this person says what can we do limit
international travel that's not
happening
uh
largest source of transportation related
greenhouse gas emissions include
passenger cars medium heavy duty trucks
light duty trucks including suvs pickup
trucks minivans
okay well so sounds like
cars are still a much bigger problem but
obviously it's just about volume there's
way more cars at any given time then
there are planes in the air well don't
look at me i've got an electric car so
i'm a [ __ ] saint oh how does your
electric car get power
you plug it in yeah
it's really renewable
okay the number one
emission was maybe it's nuclear maybe
there's there's way maybe it's not maybe
i have a solar
maybe have solar
in my house you don't know if it was
solar then it would definitely be
cleaner but it's expensive to do our
part like back in the day with electric
that thing blew up right like it was
really really like a lot of people died
anyhow i'm gonna tiptoe around this
because i want to say this so bad but it
might get cut out i don't know but there
is
a
much larger nuclear plant
oh god i missed the show so much i know
it's the biggest one
and there's fighting going on right
there and there's a live stream and
there's like a fire in the facility and
they said if it blows up it's going to
be like 10 times worse than edited the
first one that we were talking about he
says the second one will be 10 times
worse than the initial chernobyl hell
yeah have you guys heard about this
thing called uh
ceviche it happened in russia there was
that
nuke uh nuclear plant that blew up like
what's fantastic zach
you know what i'm talking about right
or some something chipotle please tell
me
you're not that dumb
um there it is though
[ __ ] mom's basement man
grip wait this is real oh my god they
already posted this
i guess so and it's just
jimmy already posted camp
so he he responded to me i guess he has
a another person
uh
working with him there are amazing
there's people [ __ ] with jimmy in our
friends what's the other guy's name it's
uh it's a girl actually
her name's carly
harley carly
jimmily camely he didn't even tag me in
this come on dude
yeah
jimmyware.shopify.com you're doing him
an old-time favor cameron
come on he needs the money cam unlike
you he needs the money cam he's a boy
really needs it he's a retiree for
christ's sake he needs to get a new tire
for his rolls well let's just finish out
the dock because we're we're basically
cruising through uh cruising through
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah watch yes thank
you zach
i acknowledge that you have to be like
yo i acknowledge that a joke was made
okay so i didn't hear you laughs and
start talking about how the [ __ ] like i
didn't say [ __ ] the people the people
spoke i am a man of the people yeah i'd
like a laugh
i want you to be a man of ethan
[Laughter]
i am a man of ethan thank you that's
that that you know what i'm saying
anyway i saw this on tick tock
it freaked me out bro they put this kid
in
one of these crazy
cars that's
they install these ungodly base
speakers in it
and i think this kid got some brain
damage like genuinely
[Music]
[Music]
at first i was like what's going on here
i didn't understand anything i was just
so captivated
[Music]
i'm serious his eyes go across here look
at this
they're laughing and [ __ ] i think they
actually hurt this kid
is that crazy
it's like he got shocked i think they
hemorrhaged and when he's like coming it
looks like he's about to start like
sobbing crying yeah
why would you do it like right at the
end
oh my god
dude
oh my god take him to the doctor please
stop laughing
yeah scary right it's almost like
disturbing
looks like he's having a good ass time
to me baby it's so hard he went
cross-eyed
oh [ __ ]
oh apparently you can have a musey
music on this person's making this up
music gun chick seizure
music on genetics
musicogenic
this person says i'm not trying to be a
debbie danner but extreme bass can throw
your heart out of the rhythm
yeah that's what we do down here in
texas boy
every young guy i make cross-eye a
chinese grandma dies of thirst
that's what it's all about
yeah
every time
every time we have a rodeo
down here in texas
a hospital in china loses electricity
it's a we estimate that our rodeo last
year
killed at least 100 chinese grandmas
yeah
we burn our trash down here boy
[Music]
i used to throw my trash away but when i
found out china was in a drought i
started to burn it as an ongoing good
buy
[Music]
i've been meaning to watch this one too
this is another great one uh i guess i
didn't know this dbz came out with a new
movie
super
yeah
is it a big deal yeah it's in a lot of
theaters it's i think it made a good
amount of money actually uh let me check
good reviews
uh yeah people seem to like it
i got spoiled for me on tick tock and
i'm pissed about it
there's a big spoiler yeah
does goku does go can die yeah go go
go
go go go go
go go can and then he dies he dies
go
this time goku can die for real boy
[Music]
uh anyway here's a clip that i thought
was pretty funny
not the best timing like the movie's
just starting he probably could have got
some
some collabs
[Music]
[Applause]
the movie started my dude
dude nobody
is [ __ ]
that's pretty good right it's pretty
good pretty funny brutal
91 of round tomatoes hey shout out
ebz i made 30 million domestically
it's not a lot yeah i guess not but i
made the most out of any dbz film prior
um what was that that was greg paul
frank paul
i didn't know he'd know how to do a
kamehameha
you know what the difference is
there was some kid talking about how and
now and for me your mama yeah they have
the
[Music]
wave in it now in fortnite and someone
some kid calls the kamehameha or
something like that kame what i don't
know how to say it what the [ __ ] is it
kamehameha kamehameha kamehameha
el yarra come on kevin you might know
that
creepy dude brags about not pulling out
all righty
trigger warning i guess i don't know
what just expect the worst of whatever
you know what the difference between me
and my couch is my couch pulls out
you know what the difference
between me and my couches
my couch pulls out [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you know what the difference
all right everybody thanks for watching
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's been a fun episode we've had a
great monday of shows
wednesday
uh wednesday we'll be back on friday
pokemon
will be joining us that's right
i'm about to kamehameha that
oh i got actually i got some
i'm about to kamehameha hilo
[Laughter]
anyway thanks for watching guys we had a
fun it was a fun app right we had a good
time it was it was good to have zach
back yeah thank you exactly thank you
thank you
laughter back there
might be the greatest tick tock i've
ever seen
i think that was off my for you think it
was yeah i don't want to out you can but
you're the best for you paige thank you
yeah i'm surprised that made it to the
dock actually but yeah i'm glad it's
glad zach it wasn't me who put that in
there i did yeah jb
it's it's a welcome back gift to zach i
guess appreciate it thank you thank you
for welcoming me back with open arms
did um your girl uh did chantelle
respond to your dick down text she is
not
she might be i'm in shock right now
lina could i spirit bomb that ass
tonight
she's not there
she saw it coming and bailed she instant
transmission all right i gotta stop the
dvd all right well we'll see you guys on
wednesday for another fantastic week of
shows big four episodes
it's the opportunity big bang i was
thinking of one yeah okay sorry sorry
ethan we're just thinking of dragon ball
z energy attacks that are sexual
innuendos yeah should we do another meta
segment this week sure
well we're banned
again we got to get another set well i
ordered one but
here
let me check
we'll have to we have to ban invade
they're going to get perma about i'm 100
sure they're going to be fully locked by
next week
bro they can brick our whole system
that's insane that's yeah that's it yeah
i want a refund
yeah what about this yo i got a funny
idea let's break it within the return
period
then return it for a refund i did order
it
yeah i mean
you could try
um it's such a hassle to make a new
account on that too like you have to
have a facebook account it was so
annoying yeah
in the whole process but i'm down to
break it and return it because [ __ ] them
i think we need to break one every week
it's very expensive uh gag no you return
it get a refund get a new one i can pick
one up if we don't wait economical
if i get banned though we can return it
ask you be like yo what's the return
policy on this
i need straight info
you can pull an ij get insurance on it
well the new one is supposed to arrive
wednesday
so we can do friday well friday we have
pokemon coming in so oh [ __ ] yeah it
might not be till next week maybe next
week then we'll be unbanned
i agree
just saying yeah let's just wait till
next week anyways because we want to
wait till we have both because then we
can do get the cameraman through we need
to just buy as many as we need and
return them after they get break i'm
just saying
don't let zucker win we we win zuck you
lose yep
it's going to [ __ ] single-handedly
destroy the meta
tear i'm i'm i'm
i'm agent smith [ __ ]
i'm coming in hey speaking of meta how
do
we miss talking about uh
i guess maybe it wasn't funny enough to
make the cut but that the vmas the
[ __ ] eminem board ape what i didn't
see it in here yeah
wait yeah what what i definitely well
it's all like copyrighted but you can
show them i guess that's true we can't
even really watch it that's probably why
we skipped
all right let's wrap it up guys thank
you see on wednesday god bless
great show everybody
have a good week
[Music]
see
wednesday
give a shout out to my family ethan a b
cam dan
gila ian laina olivia sam zack
[Music]
you